Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und ich begrüße euch hier zur 122.
Ausgabe von Raumzeit.
Und heute bin ich mal wieder auf Reisen gewesen,
oder bin es gerade, und zwar hat mich der Weg geführt nach Kopenhagen,
Konkret ans Nils Bohr-Institut in das Cosmic Dawn Center und Cosmic Dawn,
der Name kündigt es ein wenig an.
Wir blicken heute mal richtig weit zurück ins Universum und gucken uns mal an,
wie denn da die Sonne mal aufgegangen ist.
Und um darüber zu sprechen, begrüße ich meine Gesprächspartnerin,
nämlich die Anne, Anne Hutter. Schönen guten Tag.
Hallo Tim.
Herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Anne,
du bist hier als theoretische Physikerin, als Postdoc unterwegs hier am Niels
Bohr-Institut eben in diesem Cosmic Dawn Center und das gemeinsam mit vielen
anderen Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftlern,
die sich dem Universum verschrieben haben, kann man sagen.
Ja, genau.
Da gehen wir gleich mal drauf ein. Es würde mich natürlich erst mal interessieren,
was deine eigene wissenschaftliche Reise so bisher gewesen ist.
Womit hat es denn angefangen bei dir mit der Wissenschaft?
Hast du schon als kleines Kind im Sandkasten Atome resoniert?
Okay, nicht als kleines Kind.
Aber ich glaube, zumindest als Teenager war mir ziemlich klar,
ich will Astronomie oder Astrophysik machen.
Warum?
Das weiß ich bis heute nicht. Ich weiß nur, ich mochte die ganzen Star Trek
Filme und ich weiß bis heute nicht, ob es die waren, die mich auf diese Route
gebracht haben oder andersrum.
Was ist denn dein Lieblingscharakter bei Star Trek gewesen?
Spock. Natürlich.
Das hätte ich jetzt auch schon vorher sagen können. Faszinierend.
Gut, und dann bist du es auch geworden.
Ja, dann ging es ziemlich schnurstracks. Ich habe Physik in Würzburg studiert,
obwohl meine Bachelorarbeit noch nicht in der Astrophysik war.
Das habe ich dann erst zum Master geschafft.
Dann bin ich weitergegangen. Während meines Masterstudiums habe ich einen Vortrag
über den kosmischen Mikrowellenhintergrund gehalten.
Und fand das super spannend, was man im Prinzip aus, ja eigentlich nur so einer
Karte, im Prinzip was für Informationen man da rauslesen kann und was man dann
darüber lernen kann, wie das Universum sich eigentlich gebildet hat.
Das fand ich sehr spannend und dann wollte ich eben auch in die Richtung was
machen und hab mich eben umgeguckt und bin dann am Leibniz-Institut für Astrophysik in Potsdam gelandet.
Wann?
Ende 2010 habe ich dann dort angefangen. Und dann war ich da bis Anfang 2015.
Und dann bin ich danach für einen Postdoc nach Melbourne,
nach Australien gezogen, an das Center for Astrophysics and Supercomputing von
der Swinburne University und war dann drei Jahre dort und bin dann in die Niederlande,
an das Kapteininstitut an der Universität Groningen.
Und Australien und die Niederlande sind ja beide sehr radio dominiert,
wenn es geht um Radiowellen.
Echt? Ja, das hängt dann auch im Prinzip so ein bisschen mit meiner Forschung
zusammen, obwohl ich Theoretikerin bin.
Ja, warum sind die Länder so darauf fixiert? Das war mir noch gar nicht so klar.
Ich glaube in den Niederlanden ist es hauptsächlich historisch.
Australien liegt wahrscheinlich daran, dass die etliche Bereiche haben,
wo im Prinzip niemand lebt.
Die können überall Teleskope aufstellen.
Im Prinzip ja, alles, kein Radio.
Insofern passt natürlich jetzt Holland da gar nicht so richtig im Vergleich.
Aber inwiefern ist das in der Geschichte der Niederlande?
Weiß ich nicht.
Also jetzt in der Wissenschaftsgeschichte kommen einfach viele Radioforscher.
Die haben zumindest eins, ich glaube der ältesten, bin mir nicht sicher.
Also sie haben zumindest eins einen sehr älteren Radioteleskope und ja,
das hat sich irgendwie so rauskristallisiert.
Okay, die haben da ein Ding am Laufen, wir nehmen das jetzt einfach mal so hin.
Jeder hat so seine Spezialisierung, aber dass Niederlande und Australien da
auf derselben Schiene sind, das war mir selber noch nicht so ganz bewusst.
Okay, war das einfach da immer zu wechseln? Also wird man da so einfach durchgereicht
oder ist das ein großer Aufwand, sich da zu bewerben und genommen zu werden?
Ja, sicherlich. Ich meine, mittlerweile sind diese ganzen Stellen ziemlich kompetitiv.
Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Dich haben sie genommen. Ich habe immer wieder eine Stelle gefunden.
Insofern ist es vielleicht nicht ganz repräsentativ.
Vielleicht, die Frage ist eher so in Richtung, ob die sozusagen, also ob das,
dann auch immer so Institute sind, die dann auch viel ohnehin schon miteinander
zu tun haben, dass da so ein natürlicher Flow zwischen den Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftlern ist,
dadurch, dass sie sich auch mit ähnlichen Themen beschäftigen und vielleicht halt… Ja.
Teilweise. Ich sag mal in dem Fall nicht unbedingt, aber sie haben natürlich
teilweise ähnliche Forschungsschwerpunkte, was natürlich…,
Macht dann Sinn, dass man von dem einen zu dem anderen geht.
Okay. Und so war es dann wahrscheinlich auch hier.
Genau.
Ja, das Cosmic Dawn Center. Seit wann gibt es das?
Und wie wurde das so?
Also es ist ja, wenn ich das richtig sehe, so eine Kooperation der Uni Kopenhagen
und der Technischen Universität, die auch so das National Space Institute,
ist das vergleichbar mit dem DLR?
Also ist das sozusagen hier so der Körper in Dänemark, der sich so um Raumfahrt kümmert?
Ich weiß nur, dass sie auch Instrumentierung machen. Insofern würde ich das
annehmen, aber wissen tue ich das nicht genau.
Aber die sind ja auf jeden Fall mit drin und das ist sozusagen der Grund,
warum das hier eingerichtet wurde.
Ja, einer der Gründe. Ja, der Cosmic Dawn Center wurde 2018,
glaube ich, hat das angefangen.
Und im Prinzip das ist so eine, wie sich das hier nennt, Exzellenzzentrum,
wo der Dänische Forschungsbund im Prinzip Geld für zehn Jahre gibt,
für die Forschung, die sozusagen da beantragt wurde.
Ja, man sozusagen fokussiert auf ein Thema oder auf einen Themenblock forschen
kann und auch Wissenschaftler anstellen kann, um das zu bearbeiten.
Und ja, der Cosmic Dawn Center selber ist sehr fokussiert im Prinzip auf das
James Webb Space Telescope.
Hauptsächlich eben, um diese Daten auch auszuwerten. Im Prinzip war die Idee,
eins der vielen internationalen Zentren zu sein, wo man spezialisiert darauf
ist, das alles auszuwerten und zu interpretieren.
Also es war schon so klar in der Voraussicht, irgendwann wird man das Ding auch
mal gestartet bekommen und wenn es dann losgeht mit dem Datenstrom,
muss ja auch jemand geben, der sich diesem Datenstrom annimmt.
Das ist natürlich weltweit der Fall.
James Webb beschäftigt glaube ich derzeit sehr viele.
James Webb war ja hier auch bei Raumzeit schon ein Thema.
Also einerseits im Mittelpunkt einer Sendung Raumzeit 93 mit Günter Hasinger,
wo wir generell drüber gesprochen haben, was das Ding so kann und machen soll.
Auch konkret wird auch die ganze Provisionierung der Wissenschaft dann letzten
Endes läuft von der ISA von Madrid aus.
Aber natürlich mittlerweile auch bei fast jedem Thema spielt irgendwie James
Webb in irgendeiner Form eine Rolle, weil das einfach in so viele Bereiche rein strahlt.
Ja, und hier ist das sozusagen im Zentrum des Geschehens, aber es ist vielleicht
nicht die einzige Datenquelle, die hier ausgewertet wird, oder?
Nein, das ist nicht das einzige Datenquelle.
Es werden auch viele Beobachtungen mit ALMA, also auch ein Radioteleskop.
In Chile in der Atacama-Wüste, das gibt es ja schon sehr lange.
Ja, das ist glaube ich ein zweites großes Standbein und jetzt eben seit letztem
Jahr auch Euclid, das langsam auch kommt.
Genau, also der Satellit, der auch ein weiteres Weltraumteleskop,
was sich ja auch auf die Suche nach dunkler Materie und dunkler Energie gibt, Galaxien beobachtet,
hier bei Raumzeit in Sendung Nummer 117 ein ausführliches Thema schon gewesen
und mittlerweile eben auch gestartet und mittlerweile kommen auch Daten.
Also da geht es schon richtig los.
Ja, gut. Dann kommen wir nochmal so ein bisschen auf dein Forschungsfeld,
weil du hast dich ja jetzt sozusagen dieser Phase auch sehr verschrieben.
Also Cosmic Dawn heißt ja literally sozusagen quasi das Morgengrauen des Universums,
so könnte man das ja definieren.
Sprich, es geht um die Frage, was ist denn eigentlich nun damals passiert?
Und ich denke, jeder hat schon mal so ein bisschen was vom Urknall gehört.
Also sozusagen das aktuelle wissenschaftliche Bild, ein Modell kann man sagen, eine Idee,
wie all das zusammenpassen kann, was wir bisher beobachtet haben.
Und was wir uns aus unseren Vorstellungen, wie Physik funktioniert und Einstein
und anderen immer wieder bestätigten Theorien so zusammenbauen können,
wie das alles zusammenpasst mit dem, was wir beobachten.
Aber das ist halt nach wie vor ein Feld, was sich auch schwer beobachten ließ,
weil es halt einfach alles schon lange her ist.
Und ich finde es immer wieder faszinierend, weil ich denke, das ist auch vielen
Leuten nicht so klar, dass ja der Blick ins All ja auch immer ein Blick in die Zeit ist.
Wenn wir einen Stern sehen, dann ist das Licht ja nicht gerade vor zehn Minuten
entstanden, sondern es ist halt teilweise Millionen und teilweise Milliarden Jahre her,
dass dieses Licht erzeugt und auf die Reise zu uns geschickt wurde und so dieses
expandierende Universum.
Bietet uns sozusagen beliebig viel Beobachtungstiefe, nur gab es eben diese
Instrumente bisher nicht, um eben auch beliebig tief reinzuschauen.
Also beliebig tief können wir immer noch nicht reinschauen, aber es hat sich
ja einiges getan und durch James Webb ist jetzt eben nochmal so eine ganz neue
Zeit eigentlich angebrochen, kann man sagen.
Also ein neues Zeitalter der Beobachtung, wo wir jetzt also jahrzehntelang eigentlich
immer alles so ein bisschen dominiert war von Hubble,
dem Weltraumteleskop, was ja jetzt glaube ich vor ein paar Tagen schon mal so
in den vorübergehenden Ruhestand geschickt wurde.
Also es ist noch da, aber man glaubt, es hält nicht mehr lang.
Und um es noch erhalten zu können, sind sozusagen viele Systeme jetzt schon
mal runtergefahren worden.
Aber jetzt ist halt James Webb gelauncht und ist ja auch super erfolgreich gestartet
und sieht ja auch so aus, als ob es sehr viel länger auch am Leben erhalten
werden kann, als man sich das halt da am Anfang nur erträumen können.
Und wie schon gesagt, jetzt kommen halt diese Daten.
Jetzt reichert sich sozusagen auch wieder ein Blick mit Daten an,
der ja vorher eigentlich nur in der Theorie entstanden ist.
Was ist denn jetzt sozusagen unser aktuelles Bild,
also das der Wissenschaft sozusagen,
was ist sozusagen bisher der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner, der Konsens,
was da mal wohl passiert ist und womit fing es an oder was ist der früheste
Zeitpunkt, von dem wir eine Meinung haben,
wie es vielleicht angefangen sein könnte, um es mal ganz zurückhaltend zu formulieren.
Ja, also der früheste Zeitpunkt, den wir tatsächlich sehen können,
ist die sogenannte kosmische Mikrowellenhintergrundstrahlung.
Und im Prinzip, wenn wir anfangen nach der Urknalltheorie gehen,
dann hatten wir den Urknall und da gab es eine Phase, in der das Universum ganz
schnell expandiert ist.
Währenddessen sind dann auch danach dann die ganzen Teilchen haben sich geformt.
Was ist denn der Blick dann drauf, aus was es expandiert ist?
Also nicht was es war, aber wie klein wird es irgendwann mal gewesen sein, alles?
Im Prinzip der Urknall in sich selber ist eine Singularität, im Prinzip ein Punkt.
Also im Prinzip von einem Punkt zur Dimension.
Indem sich alles befindet, was wir heute sehen und meinen zu sehen.
Das ist mindboggling, oder? Das ist schwierig. Wie gehst du damit um?
Singularität und so. Kann man sich das irgendwie vorstellen?
Ist das irgendwie abbildbar?
Ich würde sagen, nein. Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen. Ich glaube,
das ist so ein bisschen wie Quantenmechanik.
Ich habe es gelernt zu akzeptieren und als abstraktes Konzept irgendwie damit zu arbeiten.
Aber es ist sehr schwierig vorzustellen, weil es komplett anders ist,
als was wir sehen oder erleben.
Gut, ich meine, es kann ja auch sein, dass das so ein sehr vorübergehender Zustand
ist. Und ganz kurz davor war es schon wieder ganz anders.
Man weiß es nicht.
Okay, gut.
Aber das ist sozusagen das Bild. Also das muss man sich ja mal klar machen.
Jetzt hätte ich fast gesagt Stecknadelkopf, aber es ist ja eigentlich mehr die Stecknadelspitze.
Ja.
Okay, und in dem war alles und das expandiert. Und dann?
Im Prinzip werden es expandiert. Also man muss sich vorstellen,
es war am Anfang wie ganz heiß. Und werden es expandiert, kühlt es im Prinzip auch ab.
Und es ist sozusagen alles, was wir an Materie heute wahrnehmen und auch vielleicht
Materie, die wir heute noch nicht,
oder die wir nur indirekt wahrnehmen, die auch noch nicht die Struktur hat,
in der wir es heute wahrnehmen.
Und im Prinzip haben sich auch erst in dieser allerersten Phase dann nach dieser
Expansion eigentlich die Teilchen gebildet.
Und irgendwann ist das Universum im Prinzip, also in bestimmten Punkten besteht
es im Prinzip aus den klassischen Komponenten, die wir kennen.
Protonen, Neutronen, Elektronen und auch Strahlung natürlich.
Und die waren ja bis zu knapp 400.000 Jahre nach dem Urknall.
Haben die sozusagen, was wir sagen, Wechselwirkung, also die Strahlung ist dann
an Elektronen oder an Protonen gestoßen und dann haben die sozusagen ihre Energie
angeglichen aneinander und damit hatten die immer ungefähr die gleiche Energie.
Aber irgendwann ist das Universum im Prinzip 400.000 Jahre nach dem Urknall,
so weit abgekühlt, dass das nicht mehr möglich ist.
Dass was nicht mehr möglich ist?
Dass sozusagen die Strahlung nicht mehr oft mit den Teilchen interagiert.
Im Prinzip kann man sich vorstellen, dann ist der Abstand einfach zwischen den
Teilchen schon so groß, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit für diese Strahlung,
dass sie ein Teilchen treffen, sehr gering ist.
Und was dann passiert ist, ist im Prinzip, dass wir eigentlich erst dann die
Elemente im Universum gebildet wurden, als der Wasserstoff, das ist der Punkt.
Also wenn wir sagen die Teilchen, dann reden wir von dem kompletten Teilchen Zoo,
von dem Standardmodell der Physik,
also da haben wir noch keine Atome und vielleicht ein Elektron,
Aber alles ist sozusagen die kleinste Einheit,
von der wir heute meinen zu wissen,
dass sie alles ausmacht, auch wenn wir noch keine Erkenntnis darüber haben,
aus was diese Teilchen wiederum bestehen und auch entstanden sind.
Das heißt, man muss sich das sozusagen vorstellen wie so eine heiße Gas-Plasma-Wolke,
also alles ist eins sozusagen, um mal metaphorisch zu sprechen.
Ich finde das irgendwie sehr wichtig, sich das so vorzustellen,
dass da nicht sozusagen ein fertiges Universum einfach nur größer geworden ist,
sondern eigentlich ist eigentlich,
wenn man das jetzt mal rückwärts denkt, ist das ganze Universum zusammen komprimiert worden,
bis es so heiß wurde, bis es in sich geschmolzen nur noch irgendwie aus,
was auch immer dann das Kleinste ist, was es sein kann, nur noch daraus besteht.
Und jetzt ist sozusagen der Urknall, ist rückwärts das Ganze abgespielt, dieser Film.
Es wird irgendwie größer und es ist aber alles heiß.
Also heiß, und jetzt reden wir wahrscheinlich von Abermillionen von Grad heiß
oder wie heiß, also furchtbar heiß.
Ja, ich nehme...
Also nicht, was eine normale Sterntemperatur heiß ist, sondern noch heißer.
Ja, definitiv noch heißer.
Ähm,
Und du sagst jetzt 400.000 Jahre und dann ist das alles überhaupt erst soweit
abgekühlt, dass es anfangen kann,
dass die Teilchen überhaupt ordentlich miteinander interagieren können,
um daraus zusammengesetzte Teilchen zu bauen.
Ja, dass wir eigentlich erst die ersten Atome formen können.
Vorher war das im Prinzip nicht wirklich möglich.
Also es gab in dem Sinne auch vorher keine Protonen oder so,
also die ganzen Quarks, die flogen dann alle noch einzeln rum?
Die gab es schon. Man kann sich das ungefähr so vorstellen.
Je kleiner der Baustein ist, desto früher hat er sich im Prinzip geformt.
Und dann mit der Zeit bilden sich aus den kleinen Bausteinen sozusagen die größeren.
Und die 400.000 Jahre ist im Prinzip wirklich die Krönungsstufe,
die allerletzte Stufe, wenn wir tatsächlich die Atome bilden.
Aber wie groß war dann das Universum zu diesem Zeitpunkt?
Wenn es sich extrem expandiert, wie groß ist es dann vermutlich erstmal geworden,
um überhaupt erstmal Atome bilden zu können?
Ist das irgendwie eine darstellbare Größe? Ist das überhaupt noch vorstellbar? Also es ist schon...
Naja, Pi mal Daumen ist es ungefähr, man kann es sich vorstellen,
tausendmal kleiner als heute.
Tausendmal? Okay, also schon recht groß. Weil tausendmal kleiner ist ja...
Ungefähr, also größenordnungsmäßig.
Okay. Also schon eine beträchtliche Expansion.
Jaja, definitiv groß. Also ich sag mal, nee, nicht irgendwie 10 Zentimeter oder 10 Meter.
Naja, keine Ahnung. War ja nicht dabei.
Nee, schon ziemlich groß.
Okay, gut. Und dann erst nimmt die Temperatur so sehr ab, dass überhaupt erstmal
eine Interaktion möglich ist zwischen den Teilchen.
Und dann haben wir Atome, beziehungsweise wahrscheinlich nur genau eine Art von Atom.
Ja, im Prinzip in dieser Phase wird dann Wasserstoff gebildet.
Und das einzige andere Teilchen, was sich danach auch noch bildet, ist Helium.
Und es gibt auch noch ein bisschen Lithium, aber mehr wird eigentlich nicht gebildet.
Also das sind alle Teilchen, die es dann quasi gibt.
Also im Periodensystem halt eins, zwei und drei.
Ja.
Ein Proton, zwei Protonen.
Und mehr existiert da auch noch nicht zu der Zeit.
Warum jetzt nicht noch das nächste Element? Also warum ein bisschen Lithium
und warum ist dann da Ende?
Im Prinzip macht das energetische im Prinzip nicht so wirklich.
Sind sozusagen die Kräfte noch nicht
stark genug, dass man die energetisch miteinander verschmelzen könnte.
Dazu braucht man im Prinzip nachher dann diese Massen und diese Kräfte,
die sozusagen dann in Sternen herrschen.
Also das nächste wäre dann Beryllium gewesen, was hätte folgen müssen.
Und dafür brauchst du dann schon Sternenbrut sozusagen, um dann was zu machen.
Also das ganze Weltall besteht jetzt im Wesentlichen aus Wasserstoff und Helium, kann man sagen.
Und sehr viel mehr Wasserstoff als Helium, nehme ich mal an.
Ja, im Prinzip ja.
Und ist das jetzt schon der Moment, wo diese Hintergrundstrahlung entsteht oder
kommt das erst noch später?
Nee, das ist genau der Punkt, als sie entsteht. Im Prinzip kann man sich vorstellen,
bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt waren die Teilchen und die Strahlung im Gleichgewicht,
also hatten dieselben Energie.
Und plötzlich wird sozusagen die Strahlung wie losgekoppelt von diesen Teilchen.
Also die bleibt dann auch, die hat so eine bestimmte, wir sagen Temperatur,
also die dann sozusagen auch die Temperatur, die damals im Universum herrschte, darstellt.
Und wir sehen sie auch heute sozusagen, ja im Prinzip bei dieser Temperatur,
obwohl natürlich sich das Ganze auch rot verschiebt.
Also wir wissen dann auch genau, wir können die Temperatur dann auch eigentlich
genau messen, die es dann dort gab, genau.
Und das ist eben das Spannende. Also diese Hintergrundstrahlung ist eben eigentlich sehr homogen.
Also es gibt nicht viele Fluktuationen. Also wenn nur ganz kleine und die sind
vier, fünf Größenordnungen kleiner als die Temperatur an sich.
Also wenn man die Temperatur nimmt und dann hat man 10.000 bis 100.000 mal kleinere
Temperaturfluktuationen.
Ich habe da noch ein Verständnisproblem mit dieser Hintergrundstrahlung.
Also ich stelle mir das jetzt so vor, man hat so diesen riesigen Blob,
so ein tausendstel Universum groß,
also sehr groß und diese Temperatur,
die dann zu diesem Zeitpunkt herrscht und die bis dahin ja so im Wesentlichen
gleichmäßig verteilt war bis auf diese kleinen Fluktuationen,
die ist ja jetzt nicht nur am Rand des Ganzen, sondern die ist ja überall.
Jetzt expandiert das irgendwie weiter.
Ist dann nicht diese Temperatur auch weiterhin überall?
Warum nehmen wir die sozusagen aus der Ferne wahr und warum ist die nicht überall?
Sie ist überall.
Auch heutzutage. Also heutzutage ist sie überall. Und wir können sie auch messen.
Also die ersten Messungen wurden zum Beispiel mit dem COPI-Satelliten gemacht.
Und dann kam WMAP und die letzte Mission war im Prinzip die Planck-Mission,
die es genau auskartiert hat im Prinzip.
Aber die Strahlung kommt ja sozusagen aus der Ferne zu uns.
Oder ist das falsche Bild?
Ja, ich würde mal mehr sagen, man kann sich vorstellen, vielleicht man hat verschiedene
Strahlungskomponenten, die in ganz verschiedene Richtungen gehen und es gibt
quasi ja nicht eine Quelle.
Im Prinzip waren im Universum ja überall, wurde diese Strahlung sozusagen losgeschickt.
Deswegen kommt sie sozusagen von überall.
Selbst wenn sich das Universum expandiert, im Prinzip relativ dehnen sich ja
auch diese, wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir haben ganz, ganz viele Quellen,
die dehnen sich ja mit aus.
Und insofern, ja, vielleicht ist das, wie man es sich vorstellen kann,
dass es von überall kommt.
Und diese Fluktuationskarte, viele werden das wahrscheinlich schon mal gesehen
haben, es wird oft so grün, blau, rot, blau dargestellt,
dann hat man halt so diese ganze Ellipse, also quasi einmal so der Blick rundherum,
so ein 360 Grad Foto und darin kann man sozusagen diese Temperaturschwankungen sehen.
Und das Ganze ist ja wie so ein Foto vom Universum zu dem Zeitpunkt,
aus dem man dann Dinge rauslesen kann, reden wir bestimmt gleich drüber.
Würde ich jetzt dasselbe machen, aber von einer anderen Stelle aus im Universum?
Würde die Karte genauso aussehen oder anders?
Prinzipiell sollte sie ziemlich gleich aussehen.
Also es ist wirklich sozusagen ein universelles Bild.
Also das gilt so überall, überall war diese Strahlung gleich verteilt oder sah sie gleich aus.
Ja, statistisch definitiv.
Was können wir der jetzt ansehen? Was sagen diese Fluktuationen aus?
Was kann man daraus deuten? Weil es hat ja zu einiger Begeisterung geführt,
auch die Bilder von Planck und so.
Im Prinzip sind diese Fluktuationen, die wir dann sehen, also manche Stellen,
wo es wärmer oder wo es kälter ist,
die sagen uns im Prinzip aus, wo das Universum anfangs ein Tick dichter und
ein Tick weniger dicht war.
Und im Prinzip sind das sozusagen die ersten Überdichten.
Das sind dann auch die Regionen, in denen wahrscheinlich die Materie sich anfängt
zu kollabieren oder zusammenzuziehen und dann auch die ersten Sterne darin zu entstehen.
Insofern gibt es uns eine Idee, wie sozusagen überhaupt die Struktur,
also wir sagen die großräumige Struktur im Universum damals ausgesehen hat.
Ja, weil so rein statistisch betrachtet, auch wenn alles im Wesentlichen eine
Temperatur hat, hat es nicht alles dieselbe Temperatur, sondern hier war es
ein Tick mehr und da war es ein Tick weniger und das sind dann sozusagen so diese Fehlstellen,
die sich dann über die Zeit verstärkt haben.
Wo es irgendwo mal heißer war, dann ist es dann auch heißer geblieben.
Wo es mal kälter war, ist es dann auch kälter geworden.
Und während sich halt alles so auseinander zieht, waren das dann vermutlich
auch die Stellen, die dann später dazu geführt haben, wo sich die Materie angereichert hat.
Weil wenn man sich heute das Universum anschaut, dann bildet es ja Stellen aus,
wo weniger ist, die Voids, also nicht komplett leer,
aber da ist dann halt nicht so viel, da hängen nicht so viele Galaxien rum,
während die Galaxien alle sich in so längeren Straßen in diesen Filamenten rumtummeln.
Und wenn irgendwo mal eine Galaxie ist und wo eine Galaxie ist,
ist eine andere nicht weit entfernt, kann man es mal so sagen.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich auch ein paar, die völlig verloren in irgendeinem Void
rumhängen und sich fragen, wie sie da jetzt hingekommen sind.
Also das hängt sozusagen unmittelbar oder davon geht man derzeit aus,
dass das unmittelbar zusammenhängt.
Ja, ja, ja, im Prinzip, ja.
Dann springen wir doch mal wieder zurück in diesen Moment, wo also jetzt die
Atome sich geformt haben.
Was ist dann als nächstes passiert?
Im Prinzip haben wir es eigentlich schon jetzt angesprochen.
Das Spannende ist jetzt im Prinzip, man kann sich vorstellen,
die Strahlung kann keine Ansammlung mehr von Teilchen sozusagen zerschießen.
Wenn zum Beispiel jetzt die Teilchen angefangen haben mit der Gravitation zu
klumpen, dann kann die Strahlung diesen Klumpen nicht mehr aufweichen.
Und somit kann die Materie immer weiter sich anreichern und verklumpen.
Und das wird dann immer alles dichter und dichter. Und damit formen sich dann die Strukturen.
Und in der klassischen Theorie, wenn man das sozusagen in erster Ordnung zum Beispiel rechnet,
wenn man annimmt, man hat eine homogene eine Massenverteilung,
also gleichförmig verteilt und sich dann fragt, wie sowas eigentlich kollabiert.
Was man dann rauskriegt ist, dass man Flächen bildet.
Also die kollabieren sozusagen in einer Dimension und dann bilden sich in der
nächsten Dimension, dann kommen diese Straßen, von denen du gesprochen hast,
also wir nennen die Filamente.
Und die letzte Struktur ist dann, wenn du mehrere Filamente hast,
dann kannst du, was wir sagen, dann halos.
Das sind, ja, Ja, sozusagen mehr kugelförmige, nicht kugelförmige Gebilde,
die dann eben nochmal dichter werden und in denen entstehen dann die ersten Galaxien.
Aber mit Galaxien geht es ja nicht los, man braucht ja erstmal ein paar Sterne für Galaxien.
Ja, gut. Die Definition, was ist eine Galaxie, ist natürlich dann auch nochmal zu diskutieren.
Ob man sowas schon mit ein, zwei Sternen sagt, das ist jetzt eine Galaxie.
Also die Sternentstehung beginnt. Und wie schnell ist das dann vorangegangen?
Also ich meine, okay, jetzt ist das irgendwie alles expandiert,
400.000 Jahre, so wumms, dann bilden sich schlagartig Atome.
Also das dürfte ja dann wahrscheinlich auch ein relativ schneller Prozess gewesen
sein, weil es ja dann sozusagen auch überall sofort oder mehr oder weniger sofort
dieselben Bedingungen geherrscht haben.
Also wurde sozusagen mit so einem Fingerschnips ab einer bestimmten erreichten
niedrigeren Temperatur wandelte sich auf einmal alles in Wasserstoff um, kann man fast sagen.
So ungefähr, ja.
Ein bisschen Helium. Und dann standen sich die Anturbe sozusagen gegenüber und
dann ging das Gravitationsspiel los,
dass dann Gas sich zusammenfindet, sich anzieht und dann ist sozusagen Sternenentstehung
mehr oder weniger automatisch das nächste, was passiert.
Kann man das so sehen oder ist das zu einfach gedacht?
Im Prinzip. Also diese Zusammenfindung von dem Gas, wir nennen das den Zeitraum
sozusagen die Dark Ages, die dunklen Zeiten, in denen es im Prinzip noch kein Licht gab.
Und die ersten Sterne, man weiß es nicht so genau, sind wahrscheinlich 100 bis
200 Millionen Jahre nach dem Urknall, haben sich wahrscheinlich gebildet.
Und das ist eben in diesen Verdichtungen passiert, wo das Gas so dicht ist,
dass es anfängt unter dem Gravitationsdruck zu kollabieren.
Also wir sind jetzt von 400.000 Jahre, wo sich das ganze Gas bildet,
mal eben 100 Millionen Jahre nach vorn.
Weitergereiht.
Und das sind die dunklen Zeiten. Ja. Okay, die Dark Ages.
Dark Ages, ja.
Und wie nennt man die Phase davor? Überhaupt einen Namen?
Ja, das ist die Phase der Rekombination. Also Rekombination.
Im Prinzip sagt man, wenn man das Wasserstoff nimmt, vorher war es im Prinzip
ein Proton und ein Elektron.
Also war es sozusagen ionisiert und dann wurde es sozusagen kombiniert.
Warum sie Rekombination sagen, weiß ich nicht.
Weil es überhaupt erstmal kombiniert wurde.
Ja, genau.
Okay, Begriffsunschärfer.
Ionisiert heißt ja, das Elektron ist irgendwie nicht da.
Sozusagen.
Das war quasi der Zustand, weil es vorher sich gar nicht zusammenfinden konnte.
Aber dann haben sich halt die Protonen gebildet und dann haben die sich quasi
die Elektronen dann geschnappt und dadurch hatte man dann Atome.
Und das ist die Kombination oder die Rekombination. Also das ist sozusagen die erste Phase.
Dann geht es halt los mit dem Wasserstoff, der dann auf dem Weg ist, sehe ich jetzt.
Aber dann dauert es halt einfach mal. Ich meine, 100 Millionen Jahre ist ja
jetzt nicht nix, sozusagen.
Und die Phase heißt dann wie?
Dark Ages. Ja, man muss sich das auch vorstellen.
Ich meine, bei der Rekombination war alles noch sehr gleichförmig verteilt.
Und wenn wir uns dann angucken, wie dicht etwas sein muss oder diese Gasansammlung
sein muss, damit sich Sterne formen, das sind ja verschiedene Größenordnungen
eben sozusagen auch höher.
Und das braucht eben auch seine Zeit, dass es sich überhaupt formen kann.
Okay, und dann haben sich diese Sterne gebildet, aber man konnte sie nicht sehen. Warum nicht?
Man könnte sie vielleicht zum Teil sehen. Also diese Sterne bilden sich und senden Licht aus.
Und wir wissen ja von der Rekombination, der Wasserstoff, der war zu dem Zeitpunkt immer noch neutral.
Das heißt, das Elektron und das Proton blieben beieinander.
Und was jetzt passiert, wenn die allerersten Sterne sich formen,
die senden ja auch Licht aus, was relativ energetisch ist, also ultraviolette Strahlung.
Und diese ultraviolette Strahlung ist energiereich genug, dass sie das Wasserstoffatom
wieder ionisieren kann.
Also sie kickt das Elektron raus. Ist das jetzt die einzige Strahlung,
die diese Sterne von sich gegeben haben?
Man würde jetzt erwarten, die geben alle möglichen Strahlung von sich,
aber nur der ultraviolette Anteil ist in der Lage, diese Elektronen wieder aus
den Atomen rauszuschießen, die sie jetzt gerade erst gefunden haben. Ist ja auch dramatisch.
Ja, genau. Aber sie geben sozusagen,
für Sterne ist es relativ genau eine Schwarzkörperstrahlung ungefähr.
Also es ist eine Verteilung über verschiedene Wellenlängen oder Energiebereiche.
Und die ultraviolette Strahlung ist sozusagen mehr der energiereichere Teil.
Man kann sich jetzt zum Beispiel auch vorstellen, je heißer ein Stern ist,
was eigentlich auch damit korreliert, dass er größer und massereicher ist,
wenn er heißer ist, desto mehr energiereiche Strahlung entsendet er auch.
Und dementsprechend, je mehr massereiche Sterne ich habe, desto mehr von dieser
Strahlung, die Wasserstoff ionisieren kann, wird auch gebildet.
Um jetzt auf deinen eigentlichen Punkt wieder zuzukommen, warum man diese Sterne
vielleicht dann nicht wirklich sieht.
Also können wir uns vorstellen, dass der energiereiche Teil der Strahlung von
dem Wasserstoff, der teilweise in der Galaxie ist, aber auch außerhalb,
also wir nennen zum Beispiel den Wasserstoff und auch das Helium,
zwischen den Galaxien intergalaktisches Medium.
Weil im Prinzip, wir haben ja nicht nur Galaxien, sondern überall anders auch das Gas.
Und diese Strahlung, die ultraviolette Strahlung von den Sternen,
ionisiert dann oder fängt an zu ionisieren den Wasserstoff im intergalaktischen Gas.
Und man kann sich das jetzt vorstellen, das ist wie eine Welle,
die sich so langsam ausbreitet.
Im Prinzip ist es eher eine Sternansammlung, was so eine erste Galaxie ist.
Das Licht wird ausgesendet, fängt an, den Wasserstoff im intergalaktischen Gas,
das direkt um die Galaxie ist, anzujonisieren. Und dann kann es ja,
wenn es den ersten Wasserstoff ionisiert hat, kann es sozusagen weiter durchgehen.
Weil es ja den ersten Teil, den er schon ionisiert hat, absorbiert ja nicht
mehr diese ultraviolette Strahlung.
Dann breitet sich das langsam auf.
Genau, und dann breiten sich diese ionisierten Gebiete langsam mehr und mehr aus.
Also alles ist sozusagen eine riesige Gassuppe.
So stelle ich mir das vor. Und durch die Verdichtung über diese Millionen von
Jahren bilden sich dann halt die Sterne.
Die Sterne sind ja im Prinzip eine Zusammenklumpung von Gas,
dann setzt halt die Fusion ein, dann wird das eben verbrannt,
das kennen wir ja von unserer Sonne auch.
Aber sind halt einfach noch umgeben von diesem neutraler Wasserstoff,
wo sozusagen alles dabei ist.
Und erst durch ultraviolette Strahlung, also durch besonders energetische Sonnen,
wird dann diesem Wasserstoff sozusagen die Elektronen weggekickt.
Sind dann nach wie vor noch Wasserstoffatome, aber die haben halt einen Elektron weniger.
Oder keins mehr. Es ist ja eh nur eins da.
Ist ja eigentlich ziemlich fies. Und jetzt haben sie sich gerade erst gefunden, ähm.
Und das dauert natürlich dann eine Weile, aber in dem Moment,
wo das stattfindet, dann hebt sich sozusagen diese Strahlung,
also in dem Moment, wo die Strahlung auf das Atom trifft, wird das Elektron
weggeschossen, aber damit ist dann die Strahlung quasi weg.
Also sie ist dann vollständig energetisch absorbiert, es strahlt dann nicht darüber hinaus.
Das ist dann sozusagen der Trade, der dann gemacht wird.
Strahlung kommt, Elektronen wird rausgekickt und das hat dann diese Energie
in dem Moment vernichtet.
Sprich, es braucht dann noch mehr Strahlung, damit dann die dahinterliegenden
Atome auch noch kommen und so weiter. Und so breitet sich das langsam aus.
Und das ist dann sozusagen diese Reionisierung des Weltalls,
die sich jetzt, naja, ich meine, in kosmischen Dimensionen dauert das dann ja
dann wahrscheinlich auch eine Weile.
Ja.
Also das ist ja dann sozusagen eine Stück für Stück, eine Beendigung dieser
Dark Ages, kann man das so sehen?
Ja, ich würde sagen, die Dark Ages, die enden wirklich mit der Entstehung der
ersten Sterne, während diese Phase der Ionisierung ist.
Eine neue Phase.
Ist im Prinzip eine neue Phase.
Und wie lange braucht die dann, bis sozusagen alles durchionisiert ist?
Ungefähr na, Na, wahrscheinlich 800, 900 Millionen Jahre ungefähr.
Ja, momentan sehen wir das ungefähr, wenn das Universum eine Milliarde Jahre
alt ist, dass im Prinzip diese Reionisierung abgeschlossen ist,
dass das Gas zwischen den Galaxien im Prinzip alles ionisiert ist, der Wasserstoff.
Das heißt, das ist jetzt auch der Normalzustand. Der ganze Wasserstoff,
der da rumhängt, hat keine Elektronen mehr.
Ja.
Das ist heutzutage immer noch so.
Aber nur deshalb kann jetzt Strahlung, die von Sternen kommt, beliebig weit reisen.
Ultraviolette Strahlung.
Die andere Strahlung, die niederenergetisch ist, die können wir sehen.
Also normales Licht kam schon immer durch?
Das sollte soweit eigentlich durchkommen.
Warum sagt man dann, dass das Universum undurchsichtig war, wenn das Licht durchkommt?
Da wird eben sozusagen darauf zurückgegangen, dass es diese ultraviolette Strahlung
ist, die so absorbiert wird.
Das ist im Prinzip auch genau der Effekt, was man sich zunutze macht, um Galaxien,
also die ersten Galaxien überhaupt zu detektieren oder zu bestimmen,
zu welcher Zeit, wie alt ist diese Galaxie im Prinzip.
Und genau das ist dieser Effekt, dass man eben sagt,
okay, zu dem Zeitpunkt war noch der Wasserstoff vorhanden,
er kann sozusagen alle Strahlung energiereicher als eine bestimmte Wellenlänge
absorbieren und dann sieht man nichts und alles,
was energieärmer ist, sehen wir.
Das heißt, wenn man dann guckt, dann sieht man sozusagen in den Spektren,
wir nennen das ein Lime Break.
Dann sieht man diese Breaks. Und je nachdem, wo dieser Break ist,
können wir sozusagen feststellen, wie alt die Galaxie oder wann sie in der Geschichte
des Universums, wie wir sie jetzt gerade sehen.
Aber nur noch zum Verständnis, weil es wird ja immer gesagt,
das Universum sei undurchsichtig gewesen. Das stimmt in dem Sinne eigentlich gar nicht.
Also das Licht, was wir sehen, das nicht ultraviolette Licht,
das konnte schon immer weiterziehen oder ist es auch von irgendetwas aufgehalten worden?
Ich meine, die andere Komponente, die das etwas sozusagen runterdimmt,
ist, wenn man hat die erste Generation der Sterne, die sich formen.
Und dann sterben die massereichsten Sterne als erstes und die produzieren ja
dann tatsächlich auch die schweren Elemente, also hauptsächlich Sauerstoff,
Stickstoff, Kohlenstoff.
Und diese Elemente bilden dann auch in den Galaxien, was wir Staub nennen.
Und Staub kann auch sozusagen die andere Strahlung absorbieren.
Und im Prinzip, wenn man sich das vorstellt, man hat diese Sternansammlung und
die produziert jetzt Staub und dann bildet sich Staub um diese Sterne,
dann kommt selbst wenn die jetzt sozusagen nicht ultraviolette Strahlung aussenden,
kann diese Strahlung teilweise von diesem Staub absorbiert werden.
Und damit wird es noch weiter gedimmt.
Der andere Punkt, mit dem das vielleicht verwechselt werden kann,
ist, dass wenn die Sterne früh im Universum ihre Strahlung aussenden,
die kommt ja bei uns rot verschoben an.
Das heißt, wenn das Universum sich ausdehnt, wird die sozusagen immer energieärmer
und damit schiebt sie sich immer mehr ins Rote,
sodass was damals ultra oder sichtbar war, eben heutzutage eher im Infrarot
ist und da für uns nicht mehr wirklich sichtbar.
Aber natürlich schon noch, also nicht für uns sichtbar, nicht für Menschen sichtbar,
aber für unsere Instrumente natürlich sehr wohl sichtbar.
Das ist ja genau das, was jetzt das James Webb Teleskop so schön macht.
Okay, aber jetzt verstehe ich auch den Punkt.
Also es gab im Prinzip zwei Unsichtbarkeiten, die zusammenkamen.
Das eine ist die ultraviolette Strahlung, die noch von dem neutralen Wasserstoff
absorbiert wurde. Die kam nicht durch.
Es gibt ja auch noch andere Strahlenkategorien, noch höher energetische Strahlung
wird vielleicht auch eine Rolle gespielt haben, aber das war sozusagen das,
was vor allem vorgeherrscht hat.
Das, was wir als Licht bezeichnen, also unter dem ultravioletten Spektrum,
das wurde zwar von diesem neutralen Wasserstoff nicht aufgehalten, aber.
Aber der ganze Prozess war ja mit Sternenbildung verbunden und am Anfang hat
sich eben sehr viel zusammengeklammert.
Und du sagst es ja schon, die Sterne, die massereichen Sterne,
also umso größer sie sind, umso schneller sterben sie.
Das ist ja im Prinzip die Regel bei Sternen. Das heißt,
die ganze Zeit sind Sterne entstanden, sind dann auch verhältnismäßig,
also alles natürlich jetzt im universellen Maßstab,
relativ schnell wieder verpufft und haben in dem Moment durch die Fusion die
neuen Elemente erzeugt, die ja sozusagen alles auch ausmachen,
was heutzutage für uns zumindest relevant ist, weil ohne Sauerstoff,
Stickstoff und so weiter wären wir irgendwie nicht so wirklich da.
Sprich, da ist dann diese Elementefabrik dann angeworfen worden und dadurch
wurde all diese ganze Wasserstoffsuppe noch um weitere Elemente bereichert,
die dann wiederum das normale Licht auch aufgehoben haben.
Und von daher war das alles noch eher dunkel. Also es ist nicht so,
dass jetzt überall komplett das Licht aus war, aber es ist auch nicht so die
sternenklare Nacht gewesen, wie wir das heute sozusagen wahrnehmen.
Ja, man kann da jetzt noch unterscheiden. Man kann sich vorstellen,
wenn man ganz sozusagen kleine Galaxien, und mit klein meine ich eben nicht
viel Masse, die noch nicht viele Sterne gebildet haben, dann kann man sich vorstellen,
die haben noch nicht viel Staub.
Weil da haben noch nicht viele Sterne sozusagen gelebt und sind gestorben.
Während wenn man sich massereichere Galaxien anschaut,
dann sind da ja viel mehr Generationen von Sternen schon entstanden und dann
auch sozusagen gestorben oder als Supernovae explodiert im Prinzip. Ja.
Und damit hängt dann auch, wie viel von der Strahlung, die von den Sternen abgegeben
wird, von diesem Staub absorbiert wird, eben von der Staubmasse ab und auch
wie viel Staub schon produziert wurde.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich für massereichere Galaxien ein bisschen höher als für masseärmere.
Jetzt haben wir, wenn ich es richtig sehe, jetzt eigentlich die wilde Phase
jetzt einmal so besprochen.
Urknall, alles irgendwie ein dickes Plasma,
dann kombiniert sich das Material zusammen zu Wasserstoff,
dann entstehen die Sterne, durch die Sterne wird der gerade schon erst entstandene
Wasserstoff seiner Elektronen wieder,
beraubt, sozusagen.
Dadurch kann Strahlung in jeder Hinsicht überall rum und Und es bilden sich
halt Sterne, es bilden sich auch automatisch Galaxien von Sternen,
weil kein Stern so für sich alleine bleibt.
Und wir blicken jetzt sozusagen auf die erste Milliarde Jahre Zeit des Universums.
Und ab da kann man sagen, geht es in Anführungsstrichen normal weiter.
Ist das so oder gibt es da jetzt noch eine Phase, die nochmal irgendwie anders
ist als das, was wir heute sehen?
Es unterscheidet sich zu dem Zeitpunkt schon sehr stark, wie es dann weitergegangen ist.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass es eine Milliarde nach dem Urknall schon so aussah
wie heute. Wir sind dann immer noch in der Phase, in der in den meisten Galaxien
viel Sternentstehung passiert.
Und das geht auch eine ganze Weile weiter.
Und erst später kommt die Phase, man kann sich das so vorstellen,
man hat die Galaxie und die wachsen ja, indem sie sozusagen das Gas immer weiter
ansammeln, was im intergalaktischen Medium ist.
Wenn man sich das so vorstellt, ja im Prinzip wird der Kontrast immer höher.
Also die Galaxien kriegen immer mehr Gas und da, wo vorher kein Gas oder wenig
Gas wird, dann ist da noch weniger Gas.
Also diese Filamente bilden sich noch stärker heraus.
Genau, genau. Der Kontrast dieser Filamente wird noch stärker.
Und jetzt kann man sich natürlich vorstellen, je mehr Gas man hat,
desto mehr Gas gibt es auch im Stern entstehen zu lassen. Das heißt,
diese Phase der Sternentstehung geht noch eine Weile weiter.
Und dann gibt es aber den Punkt im Universum, wo wir sehen, dass die allgemeine
Sternentstehungsrate,
also wenn wir uns alle Galaxien zu einem Zeitpunkt anschauen und uns überlegen,
wie viele Sterne haben die gebildet, dann sehen wir, das steigt an bis zu einem
bestimmten Zeitpunkt und dann sinkt es ab.
Und das liegt wahrscheinlich daran,
dass im Prinzip nicht mehr so viel Gas akkreditiert oder angesammelt wird.
Und dann fangen an die Galaxien, ich will nicht sagen sterben,
aber sie haben natürlich kein Gas, sie können nicht mehr viel mehr Sterne finden.
Schreibstoff ist alles.
Genau. Okay. Und dann ändern sich eben auch wie die Galaxien aussehen.
Wenn man jetzt so eine Kurve zeichnen würde, wie viele Sterne entstehen zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt.
Wie lange geht das dann sozusagen, bis der erste wirklich nennenswerte Knick kommt?
Also wann wurde das Gas alle? Knapp.
Jetzt bin ich der klassische Astronom und weiß das natürlich nur in Rotverschiebung.
Ja, das ist dann ein Z-Wert.
Nehme ich mal an. Genau.
Und welcher ist das?
Na, bei Rotverschiebung zwei. Bis dahin steigt es sozusagen an und dann fängt es an abzusinken.
Also Z, muss man vielleicht mal erklären, Rotverschiebung, das ist so ein Faktor,
den man nimmt, um das schnell mal zu klassifizieren.
Umso höher dieser Wert, umso älter ist das Licht.
Genau.
Und wenn man so ganz am Anfang schaut, dann ist man so bei 14 oder sowas.
Also, Rionisierung endete bei Rotverschiebung 6. Ja. heute sind wir bei Rotverschiebung 0,
und angefangen hat Reionisierung um Rotverschiebung wahrscheinlich 20.
Ah, okay. Okay, das ist doch mal ein brauchbarer Maßstab.
Weil so in Milliarden Jahre zu reden ist auch irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, schwer handhabbar.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen 5 Milliarden Jahre und 10 Milliarden Jahre?
Das kann man sich irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig vorstellen.
Nee, nee, in der Tat nicht. Ich finde es auch immer sehr amüsant,
wenn Astronomen sagen, das passiert ganz schnell, dann sagen sie,
das ist eine Million Jahre, das ist nichts.
Ja, das stimmt.
Jetzt noch mal die Zahlen. Also bei 20 ging es los, dann bei 6 war was?
Die Regenisierung zu Ende. Und bei 20 hat im Prinzip diese Sternentstehungsrate
angefangen zu steigen und sie steigt ungefähr bis Rotverschiebung 2.
Okay, also das hielt lange an sozusagen.
Das hielt ziemlich lange an. Ja, man muss jetzt aufpassen, Rotverschiebung 1
war vor 6 Milliarden Jahren, glaube ich, ungefähr.
Also es ist jetzt keine lineare Geschichte oder so?
Nee.
Okay.
Okay. Aber dann hat sich dann alles sozusagen auf den Level eingestellt.
Also wir sind jetzt in einer Phase, wo das Universum, sagen wir mal,
dieses maximale Wachstum im Sinne von wie viele Sterne entstehen,
wie viele Galaxien entstehen, da sind wir sozusagen über den Peak.
Natürlich entstehen immer noch neue Sterne und vielleicht auch neue Galaxien,
aber halt nicht mehr in diesem Maße, wie man es sicher beobachten kann,
wenn man eben in die Zeit guckt, also sprich ins Universum schaut und sich andere
Lichtbereiche anschaut und damit mehr in die Vergangenheit schaut,
eben weil das Universum sich ausdehnt und durch diesen Doppler-Effekt halt alle
Frequenzen in die Länge gezogen werden und damit halt sozusagen ins Rot verschoben werden.
Okay, dann haben wir doch im Prinzip einmal die Geschichte des Universums schon
mal ganz gut beobachtet.
Was ist jetzt in deinem Forschungsfokus?
Was schaust du dir jetzt genau an und wie gehst du damit um?
Momentan fokussiere ich mich auf die Galaxien, die ungefähr 200 bis 600 Millionen
Jahre nach dem Urknall entstanden sind oder existiert haben.
Und die Frage da ist, was das James-Webb-Space-Teleskop misst,
können wir momentan mit unseren Modellen, bisherigen Modellen, nicht gut beschreiben.
Und was das James Webb Space Telescope uns sagt oder die Daten zeigen,
wir haben ja vorhin schon von der ultravioletten Strahlung geredet und es gibt
ja auch den Teil, den wir noch sehen, also der nicht noch energiereich genug
ist, dass er vom Wasserstoff absorbiert wird.
Und wenn man den Teil des Spektrums, den man von Galaxien misst,
dann kann man ja messen, wie hell ist der.
Und im Prinzip, was wir sehen, wenn wir 200 bis 400 Millionen Jahre nach dem
Urknall die Galaxien uns da anschauen, die sind heller in diesem Bereich,
in dem ultravioletten Bereich, als wir dachten oder unsere Modelle es uns vorausgesagt haben.
Sie sind entweder heller oder, um es genauer zu sagen, eigentlich sehen wir
zu viele von diesen hellen Galaxien. Damit haben wir nicht gerechnet.
Jetzt gibt es verschiedene Ansätze im Prinzip, wie man das versucht zu erklären.
Und ich arbeite eben daran, wie man das erklären könnte oder was mit unseren
momentanen Modellen, wenn ich so sagen will, schief läuft.
Erklär uns doch mal, wie so ein Modell entsteht.
Also Modell heißt ja, es gibt Annahmen und man rührt jetzt diese Annahmen zusammen
mit den Daten, die man hatte. Also sagen wir mal, James Webb war noch nicht gestartet.
Sprich, was man so hatte, waren halt das, was all die anderen Missionen,
die sich bisher den Infrarotbereich angeschaut haben.
Und ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, wie weit die dann alle schauen konnten,
aber die Zs waren noch nicht so groß.
Ne, Hubble Space Telescope würde ich sagen, ja, bis Rotverschiebung 8 und James
Webb Space Telescope hat das jetzt, wir haben jetzt tatsächlich bei Rotverschiebung
14 jetzt auch die Galaxien, also die Spektren von denen schon messen können.
Das heißt, wir haben in diesem Rotverschiebungsbereich schon noch ein ganzes
Stück sozusagen weiter in die Vergangenheit, die wir gucken.
Und wenn ich das richtig verstehe, ist es so, also nicht nur,
dass James Webb jetzt quasi noch langwelligeres Licht zu messen in der Lage
ist, dadurch, dass das Ding halt so,
super runtergekühlt ist und einfach wie es eben gebaut ist,
sondern man kriegt jetzt nicht nur irgendeinen Helligkeitswert,
sondern man kann sozusagen eben auch so eine spektrale Analyse vornehmen und
sieht von daher viel tiefer in die Galaxien rein,
als das andere Instrumente bisher getan haben.
Ja, das Spannende mit Spektren ist, man kann viel mehr, wenn man das Spektrum
von Galaxien aufzeichnet, also die Lichtintensitätverteilung.
Über verschiedenste Frequenzen. Genau.
Dann kann man auch lernen, was für Elemente sind in der Galaxie.
Also sieht man, man kann darüber lernen, wie viele Sterne momentan entstehen
und eventuell auch, wenn zum Beispiel die Galaxie momentan keine Sterne produziert,
wie lang war das vielleicht ungefähr her?
Also die beherbergen jede Menge an Informationen.
Und ich glaube momentan auch so viele Informationen, die wir nicht unbedingt alle schon verstehen.
Aber ist das jetzt wirklich das erste Mal, dass Daten in dieser Form sind?
Oder hatte man das bisher nur von anderen Bereichen?
Man hatte Spektren schon auch von anderen Galaxien, allerdings nicht bei diesen
hohen Rotverschiebungen, also bei viel niedrigeren Rotverschiebungen eben näher bei uns dran.
Also wir konnten sozusagen nicht so tief ins Universum mit der entsprechenden
Analyse-Tiefe reinschauen.
Ohne jetzt sozusagen die Daten von James Webb zu haben, woraus hat sich dann
das bisherige Modell informiert?
Also wie baut man das jetzt zusammen? Ist das irgendwie…,
Das sind einfach Annahmen, Hypothesen. Kannst du uns mal so ein bisschen mitnehmen,
wie jetzt überhaupt so ein Modell entsteht? Weil ich meine, das ist ja letztlich
ein Werk der theoretischen Physik. Dafür ist sie ja da.
Es geht ja darum, sich sozusagen das auszudenken, was man nicht messen kann.
Und da irgendeine Annahme zu machen und auch eine Vorhersage zu machen.
Und wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, gab es ja viele Vorhersagen und jetzt
ist halt James Webb da und schaltet den Apparat ein und sagt so, ja nee, ist nicht so.
Ist ja auch irgendwie ein bisschen frustrierend, oder?
Oder spannend.
Oder spannend. Okay, aber wie geht man da ran?
Also was muss konkret getan werden, dass so ein Modell überhaupt erstmal da
ist? Wie funktioniert das?
Ja, man macht sehr vereinfachte Annahmen. Zum Beispiel, wenn man sich jetzt
eine Galaxie anschaut, dann überlegt man, okay, wie ist eine Galaxie wahrscheinlich entstanden?
Ich habe wahrscheinlich irgendwie Gas.
Jetzt kann ich mir überlegen, ja okay, das Gas muss wahrscheinlich eine bestimmte
Temperatur haben, damit es zu einem Klumpen weit genug kollabieren kann,
damit Sterne entstehen.
Das heißt, ich sollte eben schauen, okay, wenn ich Gas habe,
was kann das Gas kühlen, welche Prozesse?
Dann kann ich diese Prozesse sozusagen beschreiben.
Was können das für Prozesse sein?
Das sind hauptsächlich, was wir, der Fachbegriff ist Radiative Cooling, also im Prinzip.
Durch Abstrahlung.
Genau, durch Abstrahlung kühlt sich das Gas runter.
Das ist den ersten Prozess, den man sich anschauen kann. Damit kann man dann
zum Beispiel berechnen, wie viel Gas es in der Galaxie überhaupt fähig, Sterne zu formen.
Und dann nimmt man an, okay, das Gas formt jetzt Sterne.
Dann nimmt man an, muss man sich fragen, was für Sterne formen sich?
Also sind das ja massereiche Sterne oder Sterne mit niedrigeren Massen?
Und wie wir vorhin schon gesagt haben, das ist dann unterschiedlich,
was deren Strahlung dann ist, also wie viel ultraviolette Strahlung sie haben.
Und was man dann die meisten Modelle heutzutage annehmen, man nimmt die Sternenmasseverteilung
an, die wir lokal in unserer Milchstraße gemessen haben.
Weil von irgendwas muss man ja ausgehen.
Ja, das ist im Prinzip, wir wissen es nicht besser. Das heißt,
wir nehmen das jetzt einfach an.
Und dann hat man ja im Prinzip schon, man sagt, okay, so viele Sterne entstehen.
Das ist das Licht, das sie produzieren.
Dann kann ich jetzt noch ausrechnen, wenn ich sozusagen dieses intergalaktische
Gas dazwischen habe, wie viel von dieser Strahlung absorbiert wird und ab welchem
Punkt es vielleicht noch durchkommt teilweise.
Das kann ich noch draufsetzen oder auch den Staub kann dann sagen, okay.
Durch die Sternentstehung weiß ich ja, wie viele Sterne entstehen.
Ich weiß auch, dass die massereichsten Sterne als sogenannte Supernovae explodieren.
Und damit auch die Elemente, die in dem Stern dann geformt wurden,
die schweren Elemente, die werden dann in der Galaxie sozusagen verteilt.
Die den Staub bilden und dann auch diese Strahlungshäuser absorbieren.
Das kann ich im Prinzip beschreiben mit dem Modell.
Und ich kann auch weiter beschreiben, wenn diese massereichen Sterne explodieren,
dann haben wir ungefähre Abschätzungen
und Berechnungen, wie viel Energie dabei zum Beispiel frei wird.
Und das ist eigentlich auch sehr spannend, weil diese Energie,
man kann sich jetzt vorstellen, wo bleibt die?
Die muss ja irgendwas machen. Wenn ich so einen massereichen Stern habe,
der in so einem Gashaufen explodiert, dann werde ich wahrscheinlich so eine
Schockwelle haben, die im Prinzip dieses Gas erstmal wegschiebt.
Und wahrscheinlich auch dieses Gas erstmal nochmal erhitzen.
Und beides kann man sich vorstellen, A wird das Gas dann wahrscheinlich weniger
dicht und es wird wärmer.
Und das sind beides Komponenten, die nicht sonderlich zuträglich sind für Sternentstehung.
Also das heißt, wenn sowas dann passiert, dann formen sich wahrscheinlich in
der nächsten Zeit erstmal nicht so viele Sterne.
Und diese Mechanismen, die kann man sozusagen modellieren oder auch beschreiben.
Also Hollywood hat mir ja gelernt, dass die richtig tollen Wissenschaftler machen
das mal so eben am Nachmittag auf der Tafel.
Ich habe so die Vermutung, das ist nicht ganz realistisch. Was bedeutet das jetzt konkret?
Also wie viele Datenpunkte, also wir reden ja jetzt von Software,
wir reden von Computerprogrammen und von Daten, die hier gewälzt werden und wenn ich jetzt einen,
Also eine Galaxie, also ich meine, wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen,
unsere Galaxie hat, was weiß ich, 100, 200 Millionen Sterne.
Ist glaube ich so die aktuelle Annahme, so in der Größenordnung.
Und so ein Stern besteht ja aus unfassbar viel Materie, was von noch sehr viel
mehr Gas und Staub und so weiter umgeben ist.
Das sind ja Aber-Penteliaden, riesige Mengen an Atomen.
Kann man da jetzt irgendeine Zahl ausdenken und die ist dann immer noch zu klein.
Die kann ich ja nicht alle einzeln, ich kann ja nicht jedes Atom einzeln in
meinem Programm von links nach rechts schieben und mit irgendwelchen Energiewerten
belegen. Also wie quantisiert man so ein Modell?
Also wann ist so ein Modell ausreichend detailliert? Was ist da so der Faktor?
Also wie groß muss das sein, damit es irgendein brauchbares Ergebnis gibt?
Das ist ehrlich gesagt sehr, sehr unterschiedlich.
Ja.
Man hat ganz verschiedene Modelle. Es gibt zum einen die ganz simplen Modelle,
wo man im Prinzip sagt, okay, ich habe nur eine Größe, das ist wie viel Gas die Galaxie hat.
Ich habe noch eine Größe, wie viel Masse ist in den Sternen.
Und ich habe noch eine Größe, wie viel dunkle Materie ist auch noch in der Galaxie.
Und dann weiß ich meine Sternmasse, ich weiß mein Gas und dann sage ich, okay,
der Anteil oder der Bruchteil von dem Gas formt Sterne dann weiß ich,
wie viele Sterne sich gerade formen und dann nehme ich an, ich habe diese Massenverteilung
und damit kann ich direkt dann schon ein Spektrum,
vorhersagen,
Und ich kann auch sagen, okay, diese Sterne werden wahrscheinlich so viel Energie
in das Gas reinbringen, dann kann ich fragen, okay, welcher Anteil von dieser
Gasmasse, die ich hier habe, wird wahrscheinlich dann irgendwie nicht mehr kühl sein.
Wird dann sozusagen nicht mehr da sein für Sternentstehung.
Aber sind das jetzt einfach nur so isoliert Zahlenwerte, die so ein bisschen
ineinander gegeneinander gerechnet werden oder reden wir wirklich von einer
räumlichen Modellierung?
Das ist noch keine räumliche Modellierung. Das sind wirklich abstrakte Zahlen.
Pi mal Daumen.
Genau, Pi mal Daumen. Der Vorteil von diesen Pi mal Daumen Berechnungen ist
eben, dass wir das für ganz viele Galaxien machen können und damit uns anschauen
können, wie die verteilt sind.
Also habe ich da in der einen Stelle eine leuchtstärkere Galaxie,
in der anderen eine weniger leuchtstärkere.
Wie ist das verteilt? Und man kann sich auch vorstellen, das hat dann auch wieder
einen Einfluss, wie diese Reionisierung vonstattengegangen ist.
Also im Prinzip wie diese ionisierten Regionen um diese Galaxien sich ausgebreitet haben.
Und in der Hinsicht sind die eben ziemlich gut, weil sie eben schnell sind. und nicht, ja.
Und das ist dann im eigentlichen Sinne auch intergalaktisch,
also man kann sozusagen auch Beziehungen zwischen einzelnen,
also Galaxien beeinflussen, andere Galaxien. Ja.
Think big. Aber dann ist man halt nicht so detailliert sozusagen.
Man modelliert nicht jetzt wirklich so das räumliche, tatsächliche Spiel,
was in der Galaxie abliefert, sondern es geht darum, mehr oder weniger so in
Clustern zu denken, also riesigen Galaxienhaufen.
Ja, also das sind wirklich große Skalen.
Ja, und die andere Komponente, die es eben gibt, das nennen wir eine klassische
hydrodynamische Simulation oder in der Phase der Reionisierung sind es auch,
strahlungshydrodynamische Simulationen. Und was wir da machen,
oftmals, wir teilen entweder unser Volumen in kleine Zellen ein,
und dann wird quasi in jeder Zelle hat man Gas, eventuell Sterne,
und dann schaut man, wie unter den Gesetzen der Physik, also Gravitation,
Hydrodynamik, würde sich das Gas dann da bewegen und man kann natürlich dann
auch berechnen, wie stark wird das Gas gekühlt oder erhitzt und so weiter und so fort.
Und damit kann man auch wirklich dann einzelne Galaxien wirklich genauer sich anschauen.
Wie viele Zellen muss man dann aufmachen, um dann ein sinnvolles Ergebnis bei rauszubekommen?
Ja, das ist eben noch eines der großen Probleme.
Weil im Prinzip idealerweise würden wir gerne Zellen so klein haben,
dass wir die Sterne eigentlich schon auflösen können. Ist aber nicht möglich.
Also umso mehr, umso besser, aber da ist ja dann irgendwann eine Grenze,
wenn man jetzt 100 Millionen Sterne haben will, dann braucht man ja auch den
Speicher dafür und die Processing-Power.
Genau, und was wir im Prinzip dann machen müssen, ist sagen...
Wir suchen jetzt aus, wie groß unsere Auflösung ist, aber wir müssen im Prinzip,
was wir dann machen müssen, die Prozesse, die dann innerhalb dieser Zelle ablaufen,
müssen wir sozusagen, was wir ja Subgrid Models nennen.
Also sozusagen repräsentativ beschreiben, okay, ich hätte jetzt eigentlich da
so viele Sterne, aber mich interessiert im Prinzip nur die gesamte Auswirkung
zum Beispiel dieser Sterne jetzt auf,
wie hoch ist jetzt die Temperatur des Gases oder wie dicht ist jetzt das Gas.
Aber ich kann in dieser Zelle nicht genau auflösen, hier ist es dichter,
da ist es weniger dicht und so weiter.
Das ist eben eine der großen Herausforderungen, was man mittlerweile eben auch
probiert und sagt, wir machen eben verschiedene Simulationen,
machen eben Simulationen, wo die Zellen im Prinzip ganz klein sind.
Wir können das alles auflösen und dann schauen wir uns an, okay,
wenn wir zum Beispiel die Sternenpopulation
haben, dann beeinflusst das das Gas in der Art und Weise.
Dann können wir das, was wir nennen, parametrisieren, also beschreiben,
wie wenn ich die Konditionen habe,
dann kommt das raus und das kann ich die Resultate in eine Simulation einbauen,
wo sozusagen meine Zelle größer ist.
Und damit habe ich im Prinzip so ein bisschen imitiert, was eigentlich passieren
würde auf kleineren Skalen.
Das heißt, man hat keine uniforme Zellenaufteilung, sondern Bereiche,
wo mehr passiert oder wo die Interaktion komplexer ist, die werden höher aufgelöst
und andere Bereiche, wo weniger passiert, werden gröber aufgelöst.
Ist, nur um jetzt mal so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, angenommen,
ich würde jetzt also unsere Milchstraße mal so jetzt modellieren,
also sozusagen in der Größenordnung gedacht.
Ja.
Auf wie viele Zellen würden wir dann kommen? Also was wäre machbar mit einem
heutigen Computersystem, mit der Technik, die euch hier auch zur Verfügung steht,
der Processing Power, die ihr nutzen könnt?
Ist das jetzt eine sehr kleine Zahl oder eine sehr große Das sind ja auch alles
Werte, die man einstellen muss am Ende, wo ja auch Entscheidungen gefällt werden müssen.
Wie genau lasse ich jetzt dieses Modell rechnen?
Ja, ganz genau weiß ich es nicht. Ich nehme an, für eine einzelne Galaxie kann
man das noch relativ gut, also genaue Zahlen weiß ich leider nicht.
Da reden wir von 10 Zellen, 100.000, 10.000, 100.000, eine Million,
10 Millionen, wie viel sind das?
Das sind schon mindestens um die Ordnung 10 hoch 9, also eine Milliarde. Ja, Milliarde.
Okay, nur um eine Vorstellung zu bekommen. Also man baut sozusagen sich ein
Softwaremodell, was aus einer Milliarde Orten besteht, die dann bestimmte Räume
repräsentieren, die parametrisiert sind.
Hier ist so und so viel Gas, hier ist so und so viel von dem Element,
von dem Element, von dem Element.
Die Temperatur davon ist und so weiter. und dann lässt man das irgendwie alles
laufen und rechnet das sozusagen über einen längeren Zeitraum durch und schaut, was passiert.
Genau, genau.
Und dann glühen die Rechner und man hat dann erstmal drei Wochen nichts zu tun
und wartet nur auf das Modellergebnis.
Oder ist das etwas, was die ganze Zeit immer läuft?
Also habt ihr diese Modelle permanent im Betrieb und die verfeinern sich die ganze Zeit?
Oder ist das etwas, was man mal so am Wochenende laufen lässt und dann guckt
man sich montags das wieder an?
Also typischerweise würde ich sagen, gibt es sozusagen die Entwicklungsphase,
wo man den Code, um die Simulation laufen zu lassen, eigentlich erstmal entwickelt.
Das heißt, und auch zu testen, ob der eigentlich das macht, was man will,
lässt man meistens kleinere, also weniger stark aufgelöste Simulationen laufen
und testet, dann kommt jetzt ungefähr das raus.
Die kann man meistens irgendwie auf einem lokalen Cluster laufen,
vielleicht auch wenn man es klein genug macht, auf einem eigenen Computer laufen lassen.
Und wenn man dann an einem Punkt angekommen ist, wo man seinem Modell vertraut
und sagt, okay, der Code ist jetzt gut genug und er scheint auch was zu reproduzieren,
was Sinn macht, dann geht man sozusagen in die Produktionsphase.
Also dann kann man auch größere, also besser aufgelöste Boxen simulieren.
Und das ist aber für diese Art Simulation, also vor allem für die hydrodynamischen
Simulationen, wo wir auch die Strahlung mit reinnehmen, explizit, werden die sehr teuer.
Also das ist schon in der Größenordnung mehrere Millionen CPU-Stunden.
Das heißt, da muss man schon in die Computing Cluster oder High Performance
Computing Systems gehen Das.
Muss man dann beantragen oder habt ihr so ein Kontingent?
Das ist unterschiedlich je nachdem wo man ist Also wenn das Institut natürlich
schon irgendwie genügend Computing Power hat und man das zur Verfügung hat, kann man das nutzen,
Ansonsten muss man die beantragen die Rechenzeit Rechenzeit,
das geht dann ganz klassisch, so ähnlich wie bei Teleskopen.
Und gibt es hier genug Power im Keller?
Wir haben Zugang zu einem Supercomputer in Finnland, über die Uni hier.
Aber wenn es wirklich größer wird, müssen wir auch beantragen, Rechenzeit. Okay.
Das heißt, man baut sich jetzt, nehmen wir mal an, okay, Software ist jetzt
lokal getestet, sieht alles total super aus, wobei es ja schwierig ist,
jetzt so ein Modell auch zu bewerten, weil letzten Endes versuchen diese Modelle ja sozusagen.
Irgendein Szenario zu beschreiben, was man ja so gar nicht überprüfen kann,
weil es ist ja ein Modell.
Also es ist ja sozusagen überhaupt erstmal eine Voraussage. Das ist ja der Versuch
einer Vorhersage für, also meiner Auffassung nach müsse das so aussehen.
Und meiner Meinung nach bedeutet das, dass sich in diesem Zeitraum Galaxien
dieser Größenordnung, in dieser Form, in dieser Geschwindigkeit entwickeln müssten.
Das ist ja sozusagen das, was man versucht aus diesem Modell herauszulesen.
So eine Beschreibung dessen, was man, immer noch James Webb ist nicht da,
man macht halt Annahmen auf Basis dessen,
was man bisher gesehen hat und wofür es Daten gibt und wie viele Ideen kommen da noch mit dazu?
Also ist das alles datenbasiert oder sitzt man dann da auch so und sagt sich so,
okay, jetzt habe ich hier noch so eine super Theorie, was die Welt im Innersten
zusammenhält und das baue ich
jetzt einfach mal an das Modell ein und dann gucke ich später, was ist.
Oder verlässt man sich einfach nur auf das, was bisher gesehen wurde?
Ja, also Modelle werden normalerweise, was wir nennen, kalibriert.
Das heißt, es gibt bestimmte, in den meisten Modellen bestimmte Parameter,
zum Beispiel wie effektiv Sternentstehung ist, also welcher Anteil des Gas formt Sterne.
Und bei diesen Kalibrierungen kann das Modell ja voraussagen,
zum Beispiel wie viel ultraviolette Strahlung wir sehen würden oder was gemessen wurde.
Und das heißt, man versucht das Modell auch dahin zu kalibrieren,
dass es das erstmal produziert.
Das heißt, bestimmte Beobachtungsdaten benutzen wir sozusagen als Kalibrierungsdatenset.
Aber so eine Hutter-Konstante oder so hast du noch nicht eingebaut?
Nein.
Könnte ja sein, dass man da irgendwie auf solche Ideen kommt.
Okay, was haben denn diese Modelle, die es bisher gab,
über diese Zeit des Universums gesagt und wie hat das dann zusammengepasst mit dem,
was man jetzt von James Webb an neuen Beobachtungen bekommen hat und von vielleicht
anderen Satelliten, die jetzt in letzter Zeit noch dazu beigetragen haben?
Ja, was die Modelle gesagt haben, sie haben im Prinzip gesagt,
wir haben eine bestimmte Anzahl von Galaxien, die eine bestimmte Leuchtkraft
im Ultravioletten haben.
Und die war ungefähr 200 bis 400 Millionen Jahre nach dem Urknall.
Leicht niedriger die Anzahl von diesen leuchtstarken Galaxien verglichen mit
dem, was jetzt das James-Webb-Space-Teleskop beobachtet hat oder wir sehen.
Und jetzt gibt es eben so verschiedene Theorien dazu, warum das so ist.
Und momentan wird stark geforscht, wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel die Annahme ändern
oder die, wie würde sich das auswirken? Würde das das erklären?
Also zum Beispiel, was man machen kann, ist, die meisten Modelle bisher nehmen
an, wir nehmen die Sternmassenverteilung von heute.
Aber man kann sich dann auch überlegen, in den ersten Galaxien ist das wahrscheinlich
nicht unbedingt der Fall.
Weil wenn man zurück in die Sternentstehung geht, kann man sich ungefähr vorstellen,
wenn man Sterne nur aus Wasserstoff und Helium produziert, dann sind das meistens
sehr massereiche Sterne.
Das heißt, sie sind sehr leuchtstark.
Aber sobald wir dann auch noch andere Elemente haben, das Gas im Prinzip nicht
nur Wasserstoff und Helium ist, sondern auch Kohlenstoff, Stickstoff,
Sauerstoff hat, dann kann das Gas auch besser kühlen.
Also es kann zu niedrigeren Temperaturen runtergekühlt werden und damit entstehen
dann auch weniger massereiche Sterne.
Und das ist natürlich heutzutage in unserer Milchstraße, haben wir eben viel
mehr Generationen von Sternen,
sind da schon entstanden und haben das auch angereichert und dementsprechend
sind unsere Sterne auch weniger massiv oder weniger massereich.
Und damit kann man sich vorstellen, wahrscheinlich bei den ersten Galaxien waren
eben die meisten Sterne eigentlich viel massereicher, als was wir jetzt gerade
in unseren Modellen annehmen.
Also unsere Sonne ist ja nicht so fett im Vergleich.
Ne, die ist, wenn man es sich so vorstellt, ist es eine Sonnenmasse und die
Sterne, von denen wir reden, naja, also.
Massereich heißt? Ja.
Masse heißt in der Astronomie oft ab 8 Sonnenmassen, aber kann hochgehen bis
100, 200, man weiß es nicht genau, Sonnenmassen.
Was ist so die größte Sonnenmasse, von der man heute weiß?
Also was ist so der fetteste Stern, in welcher Größenordnung bewegt sich das?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Ich glaube, die hat man nicht unbedingt direkt
gemessen, die hat man auch teilweise einfach durch ihren, wie ich es sagen will,
Elementfußabdruck, den sie hinterlassen haben, also welche Elemente sie produziert
haben, das kann man teilweise im Gas messen und mit Modellen sozusagen berechnen,
das muss wohl irgendwie so ein massereicher Stern gewesen sein.
Ich weiß es nicht genau, aber ich würde annehmen so um die 100 Sonnenmassen.
Aber unsere Sonne, wir sind ja überhaupt, also insofern sind wir vielleicht
mal was Besonderes, weil wir so eine kleine Sonne haben und es funktioniert trotzdem noch.
Immer der Versuch irgendwie, was Tolles zu sein hier. Aber wir sind ja eigentlich
ganz durchschnittlich, was viele Sachen betrifft.
Ja, wir sind auch sehr zahlreich, wenn es um Sonnenmassen oder Sterne mit Sonnenmasse geht.
Das ist ja allgemein so, wenn man sich anschaut, die Verteilung von den Massen,
von den Sternen, die sie formen. Es formen sich meistens viel mehr niedrigmassige
Sterne, sehr massereiche Sterne.
Also hier wird gerade mal so ein bisschen rumgeforscht aber ich glaube ESO meint
einen Stern gesehen zu haben mit 320 Sonnenmassen,
und hat heute noch 265 also in der Größenordnung Okay,
Okay das heißt wir müssen das jetzt interpretieren also die James-Webb-Daten
sind reingekommen und dann war das so naja im Wesentlichen lagen wir richtig,
jetzt müssen wir noch an ein paar Parametern,
schrauben und passt schon?
Oder war das eher so mit oh weia, ist alles anders, als wir gedacht haben,
wir können jetzt alle unsere Modelle wegschmeißen?
Also mit den allerersten Daten,
da war das tatsächlich, da war der Unterschied auch noch viel größer.
Zwischen den Modellen und den Beobachtungen. Da war das schon so ein bisschen okay.
Also was genau war dann größer, also was hat diesen Unterschied im Wesentlichen ausgemacht?
Größe der Galaxien oder Menge der Galaxien?
Nee, die Leuchtstärke. Einfach wie viele leuchtstarke Galaxien da sind.
Das waren einfach viel mehr, als wir erwartet haben. Okay.
Das hat sich jetzt, am Anfang muss man sich vorstellen, die Beobachtungen wurden
eben relativ schnell ausgewertet.
Das heißt, man hat da nicht die ganzen Spektren bekommen von den Galaxien.
Man hat nur Datenpunkte in bestimmten Energiebändern bekommen.
Also wenn man einen bestimmten Wellenlängenbereich nimmt, dann weiß man,
ich habe die Intensität von dem Wellenlängenbereich.
Somit hat man aber nur eine begrenzte Anzahl an Datenpunkten.
Da kann man natürlich alle möglichen Spektren annehmen, die diese Datenpunkte
wahrscheinlich beschreiben.
Okay, aber man wusste, wie viel Energie da ist, aber man wusste nicht,
wie sie verteilt ist und wie sie sich auf die einzelnen Frequenzbereiche verteilt.
Aber es war dann schon so, alle Theoretiker haben da so einen Schockmoment bekommen
und gesagt, oh Gott, das Software taugt gar nichts. Das war wahrscheinlich so die Angst, oder?
Ja, obwohl wenn man sozusagen das Beobachtungsfeld kennt, weiß man auch,
wenn diese Art von Beobachtungen kommen….
Heißt das erstmal noch gar nichts.
Das will ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber…,
Galaxien man hat, gesteigert. Dann hat sich das mehr angenähert.
Also die Anzahl der Leuchtstarken-Galaxien ist im Prinzip runtergegangen.
Okay, also ihr werdet nicht alle sofort gekündigt, sondern es hat schon auch ein bisschen gepasst.
Also es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass jetzt diese Modelle…,
eine Realität versucht haben zu beschreiben, die so gar nicht existiert.
Das kann man auch nicht sagen. Nee, also ich sag mal bis Rotverschiebung 10,
ungefähr 400 Millionen Jahre nach dem Urknall, also alles bis 400 Millionen
Jahre nach dem Urknall, haben die Modelle auch gut beschrieben.
Es war nur das Problem, alles was sozusagen früher war.
Ja.
Das sieht anders aus. Also man ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen zu früh,
jetzt hier irgendwelche Zusammenfassungen zu machen, aber wie viel Auswirkung
scheint das zu haben, was da an Datenmaterial jetzt kommt?
Also wie sehr wird das die Modellierung und unser Verständnis von dem,
was in dieser Phase passiert ist, ändern?
Wir bekommen schon entscheidende Informationen, die wir vorher nicht hatten, definitiv.
Wir werden viel mehr lernen über die ersten Galaxien, wie Galaxien entstanden
sind und was ihre Eigenschaften waren, welche Arten von Sternen geformt werden.
Auch zum Beispiel das Heranwachsen von den schwarzen Löchern,
wie schnell die sozusagen gewachsen sind, ob die so aussehen,
wie wir es bisher kannten oder nicht.
Es sieht momentan so aus, dass wir im Prinzip eine ganze Art von Galaxien sozusagen
neu entdeckt haben, die wir vorher gar nicht gesehen haben.
Das sind alles solche Entdeckungen, die jeder in sich eigentlich sehr interessant
ist und auch viele physikalische Fragen aufwirft und die eigentlich sehr fundamental sind in dem,
wie wir Galaxienentstehung verstehen und welche physikalischen Prozesse da relevant sind.
Jetzt hast du ja vorhin schon bei der Modellierung gesagt, was du da alles so
reinschmeißt in deinen Kochtopf sozusagen.
So ja, hier Gas, Temperatur, Elemente, dunkle Materie packen wir auch noch mit rein.
Nein, da muss ich jetzt natürlich nochmal nachhaken, weil das ja so ein Dauerbrenner
ist, weil die dunkle Materie, also die Materie, von der man annimmt,
dass sie da ist, weil wenn sie nicht da wäre,
dann macht das mit der Gravitation auf einmal alles keinen Sinn mehr und Galaxien
könnten nicht so aussehen, wie sie aussehen.
Also nimmt man an, dass sie da ist aber man sieht sie halt nicht und man weiß
weder warum man sie nicht sieht oder woraus sie bestehen könnte,
also sozusagen eines der ganz großen Fragezeichen der Kosmologie die aber trotzdem
jetzt in so ein Modell einfach mal so reingeschmissen wird, weil gibt's halt, so denkt man,
kann das was jetzt sozusagen gerade entdeckt und analysiert wird in dem Bereich
irgendwelche neuen Erkenntnisse liefern?
Also Erkenntnisse vom James Webb Space Teleskop würde ich jetzt erstmal denken,
eher unwahrscheinlich, bin mir natürlich nicht sicher, aber,
wenn es um dunkle Materie und vor allem dunkle Energie geht,
dann ist es hauptsächlich,
Euclid, wo man sozusagen große Gebiete beobachtet und sich dann anschaut,
wie die Verklumpung oder die Verteilung von Materie sich ändert.
Im Bereich der Galaxien selber ist das Problem, dass unser Verständnis von der
eigentlichen Gasphysik und die Sternentstehung so groß ist,
dass es sehr schwer wird, viel über eigentlich dunkle Materie an sich zu lernen.
Das Einzige, wo man eventuell was mit lernen kann, Aber das ist nicht unbedingt
James Webb direkt oder vielleicht auch indirekt.
Es ist im Prinzip der Zeitpunkt, wenn die ersten Galaxien sich formen.
Das kann etwas zum Beispiel über die Eigenschaft von der dunklen Materie aussagen.
Zum Beispiel, wie wir sagen, wie warm oder wie kalt sie ist.
Das heißt im Prinzip, auf welchen Skalen kann sie klumpen.
Und man kann sich vorstellen, wenn sie im Prinzip auf kleineren Skalen klumpen
kann, dann bilden sich die ersten Galaxien viel früher im Universum.
Also in der Hinsicht würde ich sagen, kann das James Webb Space Teleskop,
wenn es sozusagen sagen kann, wann die ersten Galaxien sich vor dem Indirekt
eine Aussage darüber machen.
Aber ich würde das sehr mit Vorsicht genießen und eigentlich sagen,
da braucht man eigentlich eher Experimente, die das nicht nur fokussiert auf
einzelne Objekte, sondern die Gesamtheit der Objekte.
Also wie es Euclid macht. Ich wollte es jetzt auch gar nicht so sehr auf James
Webb festlegen, sondern sozusagen auf die aktuellen neuen Beobachtungssysteme.
Also man kann es ja ein bisschen weiter aufdrehen und da gehört natürlich jetzt
Euclid auf jeden Fall auch noch mit dazu.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es noch andere Systeme gibt, außer jetzt diesen beiden,
die jetzt gerade in diesem Bereich wichtige neue Daten liefern.
Ich meine, ein anderes Instrument, was in den nächsten hoffentlich fünf Jahren
dann auch kommt, ist das Square Kilometer Array.
Was auch dann die Materieverteilung im Universum, wirklich im frühen Universum,
Cosmic Dawn und eben zu den Dark Ages, also in dunklen Zeiten,
die sozusagen abbilden wird, ja so eigentlich sogar 3D.
Das ist ein neues Radioteleskop, was in Australien gebaut wird.
Genau.
Und noch nicht ganz fertig ist, aber ich glaube so in drei Jahren oder so irgendwie. viel.
Ja, die sind momentan in der Konstruktionsphase. Und soweit ich glaube,
den ersten Konstruktionsphasenschritt haben sie jetzt abgeschlossen und sie
kriegen, glaube ich, jetzt auch die allerersten Daten rein.
Aber wirklich, was wir First Light nennen, also wenn das Teleskop wirklich anfängt
zu beobachten und ist auch offen dann für die Forschungsgemeinde,
ich glaube soll 2029, ist momentan angepeilt.
Ja.
Wikipedia sagt noch 27, aber das kann sich natürlich auch alles verschieben.
Okay, also das ist sozusagen ein ganz wichtiges neues Instrument, was noch mit dazu kommt.
Und das er von der Erde aus macht, ganz klar. Also Square Kilometer heißt halt
einfach auf einen Quadratkilometer mehrere einzelne Radioteleskopantennen verteilt,
die dann sozusagen in der Kombination alles wahrnehmen, was ankommt.
Ja, was die im Prinzip wahrnehmen, ist eine Strahlung, die kommt vom neutralen Wasserstoff.
Gibt es doch noch welchen?
Das ist genau der Spaß daran.
Ich dachte, der wäre jetzt alles wegionisiert.
Ja, deswegen kann das Square Kilometer ja auch nur die Zeit sozusagen vor oder
während der Ionisierung anschauen.
Aber das ist natürlich auch sehr spannend, weil was wir damit auch dann sehen
können, wenn es wirklich so 3D-Karten von der Verteilung von dem neutralen Wasserstoff.
Das heißt, wir können da auch sehen, wie diese ionisierten Regionen um die Galaxien
sozusagen wachsen mit der Zeit.
Und dann kann man sich natürlich vorstellen, wenn man das analysieren kann,
kann man dann auch Rückschlüsse auf die ersten Galaxien nehmen.
Sehr interessant. Das heißt, dieses Square Kilometer Array,
liefert quasi nochmal einen komplett neuen Daten Ein Datenpunkt,
den es so noch gar nicht gibt, der so ein bisschen vergleichbar ist vielleicht
mit dieser kosmischen Hintergrundstrahlung, weil es ja auch so ein globaler
Schnappschuss einer alten Zeit des Universums dann ist.
So ungefähr, genau.
Das ist sehr spannend. Also man kann sich das so vorstellen,
das ist wie so eine Tomografie, wo man an jeder Zeitpunkt dann sozusagen eine 2D-Karte bekommt.
An der Stelle ist es neutral, da ist es ionisiert.
Und dann kann man sich vorstellen, je weiter man sozusagen in die Vergangenheit
geht, je neutraler wird es dann. Und man kann auch sehen, okay,
habe ich hier ganz viel neutralen Wasserstoff oder habe ich weniger neutralen Wasserstoff?
Das heißt, ganz am Anfang sieht man sozusagen auch die allerersten Filamente
und die überdichten Regionen, wo dann wahrscheinlich auch die Galaxien anfangen.
Aber was strahlt denn dieser neutrale Wasserstoff ab, dass man das jetzt noch
messen kann auf der Erde?
Im Prinzip ist es eine Wechselwirkung mit der kosmischen Hintergrundstrahlung.
Man nennt es die Hyperfeinaufspaltung des neutralen Wasserstoffs.
Das ist auch ein Energieübergang.
Und man kann sich jetzt vorstellen,
dass die kosmische Mikrowellenhintergrundstrahle sozusagen den neutralen Wasserstoff
in einen höheren energetischen Zustand versetzt und dann geht er eben wieder
runter und emittiert dabei ein Photon und das ist die klassische 21 Zentimeter Linie.
Ah, okay. Und sogar sowas kann man noch messen.
Was haben wir denn jetzt sozusagen gelernt aus all dieser Modellierung und Auswertung
der ganzen Beobachtungen bisher über Galaxien?
Also was lässt sich da sozusagen herausziehen bisher?
Also klar, man weiß, dass sie entstehen und so weiter und in welcher Größenordnung
und so weiter. Aber was folgt daraus?
Was ist sozusagen die Erkenntnis, die man aus dieser Forschung gewinnt vor allem?
Was wir definitiv sehen ist, dass die ersten Galaxien energiereichere Strahlung hatten.
Also die Sterne haben energiereichere Strahlung abgestrahlt.
Damit könnten es wahrscheinlich massereichere Sterne sein.
Wir wissen auch, dass es teilweise Galaxien gibt, sehr junge,
oder wenn das Universum noch relativ jung ist, die schon relativ viel Staub haben.
Das ist auch eine Frage, die so ein bisschen uns umtreibt.
Also wo viele Sterne schon in Supernova aufgegangen sind.
Ja, aber vielleicht missinterpretieren wir auch das Spektrum, auch möglich.
Aber bisher haben die eben auch einfach viele Fragen aufgeworfen.
Ja, ich glaube, zusammenfassend lässt sich sagen, wir haben gelernt,
sie haben wahrscheinlich energiereichere Strahlung.
Wir können auch definitiv sehen, dass das Gas weniger angereichert ist mit,
was wir metallikern, also Kohlenstoff, Sauerstoff, Stickstoff und all die schweren
Elemente als Wasserstoff und Helium und Lithium.
Das können wir definitiv sehen.
Und ich glaube ansonsten hat es auch viele Fragen dann einfach aufgeworfen.
Was sind jetzt die ersten Sterne? Wie beeinflussen sie das Gas und was bedeutet
es dann für die Sternentstehung danach?
Und das ist ja eigentlich noch so ein bisschen so ein Fragezeichen.
Es ist nicht auch eine Beobachtung gewesen, dass man auch bestimmte Ausprägungen,
es gibt ja verschiedenste, haben wir noch gar nicht so drüber gesprochen, Galaxieformen.
Ja, man kennt halt diese Andromeda Milchstraße, die halt so Balken- und Spiralgalaxien sind.
Dann gibt es ja kugelförmige Ellipsoide, alle möglichen ganzen,
weiß gar nicht wie viele verschiedene Galaxientypen so unterschieden werden, so 10 oder sowas.
Kann das hinhauen in etwa in Größenordnung oder sind es schon mehr?
Es gibt auf jeden Fall verschiedene Typen und man hat glaube ich von bestimmten
Galaxiearten angenommen, dass
die auch viel Zeit brauchen, um überhaupt erstmal so sich auszuformen.
So eine Balkengalaxie, da muss halt erstmal viel passieren und wenn das nicht
erstmal alles ein paar hundert Milliarden Jahre um sich herum rotiert ist,
dann kann das erstmal nach gar nichts aussehen.
Und jetzt, glaube ich, hat man auch schon mal mit James Webb gesehen,
so, ja, nee, ganz so ist es jetzt auch nicht.
Ja, ein Klassisches ist, dass man, also Galaxien, die traditionellen, die haben so Scheiben.
Also klassische Spiralgalaxie, kann man sich vorstellen, die Spirale ist jetzt so eine Scheibe drin.
Und was jetzt diese Daten im Prinzip sagen, dass diese Scheiben sich eventuell
schon sehr früh ausgeprägt haben.
Allerdings muss man da auch berücksichtigen, dass wahrscheinlich in dieser frühen
Zeit diese Scheiben noch nicht so dünn waren, wie wir sie heute teilweise sehen,
sondern viel, viel dicker.
Und das andere ist, dass natürlich weil es so weit weg ist, können wir sie teilweise
auch nicht so gut auflösen räumlich das heißt wir kriegen nur so ein paar Pixel
und dann basierend auf den Messungen von den Spektren von diesen Pixeln,
machen wir dann diese Schlussfolgerung aber es sieht so aus,
ob die schon rotieren, also das in jedem Fall.
Und das war jetzt auch nicht unbedingt erwartet worden?
Das ist eine offene Forschungsfrage Also die Antwort war nicht klar.
Wenn ich jetzt mal so ein Mysteriumskoeffizienten abbilden möchte,
also wie gut haben wir diese Galaxienbildung verstanden?
Also wenn man jetzt sagen würde, oh, was wissen wir denn schon?
Wissen wir jetzt schon alles? Wie viele Fragezeichen gibt es da noch?
Wie kommt ihr das so persönlich vor? Boah, wir wissen gar nichts oder wir kratzen
an der Oberfläche oder naja, so im Wesentlichen haben wir es schon irgendwie drin,
aber es fehlen noch ein paar Daten oder das war es jetzt. Was würdest du sagen?
Ich würde sagen, naja zu Nullter und vielleicht Erste Ordnung haben wir ein grobes Verständnis.
Erste Ordnung heißt jetzt was?
Ja, wir haben ein grobes Verständnis von den ungefähren physikalischen Prozessen,
die wahrscheinlich eine Rolle spielen und was sie dann bewirken.
Aber im Detail wissen wir das eigentlich, also wie genau und wenn ich jetzt
den einen Parameter da vielleicht verändere, wie genau sich das dann auswirkt.
Im Prinzip in dem Moment, wo ich es ein bisschen mehr komplizierter mache,
dann werden da schon viele Fragezeichen. Das ist alles nicht klar.
Okay. Und wie wichtig ist das Verständnis der Galaxienbildung für das Gesamtverständnis Universum?
Ist das so der Schlüssel dafür?
Na, ich würde sagen, im Prinzip ist es so ein bisschen Beantwortung der Frage, woher kommen wir?
Ich sage mal, die ersten Galaxien ist sozusagen die Sternentstehung,
das ist im Prinzip eventuell dann auch die Elemente, aus denen wir gemacht sind
und überhaupt zu verstehen,
warum dann auch unsere Galaxie so aussieht, wie sie aussieht.
Das ist im Prinzip die Antwort auf, ja.
Aber es ist jetzt sozusagen nicht nur ein, wie sieht es am Ende aus,
sondern man kann aus dem Verständnis, wie es sich so gebildet hat,
um da hinzukommen, wo es heute ist, auch Aussagen darüber machen,
was vorher passiert ist.
Ja, zum Teil schon.
Weil man es jetzt auch gar nicht modellieren könnte.
Ja, also das hängt immer davon ab, was vorher passiert ist. wie etwas dann danach auch aussieht.
Und ich glaube auch, das ist, warum es so komplex ist, weil es eben so viel
passieren kann und so viele Komponenten mit reinspielen, dass es sehr schwierig
dann auch komplett zu verstehen ist.
Wenn jetzt Raumfahrt wünscht dir was wäre, ja,
theoretische Physikerin darf sich jetzt sozusagen ein Beobachtungssystem wünschen,
was dann einfach gebaut wird, weil kein Problem, Leben, Geld spielt keine Rolle, Technik, alles gelöst.
Was wäre so dein Wunschgerät? Egal ob das jetzt auf der Erde ist oder im Weltall
rumkurvt, was müsste sich das anschauen, auf welche Art und Weise,
wo du das Gefühl hast, okay, das wäre jetzt aber wirklich mal genau das,
wo ich Sachen rauslese, wo absehbar ist, wo wir mit den heutigen Instrumenten,
soweit die die uns auch bringen, vielleicht da nie wirklich eine Erkenntnis haben.
Also selbst mit James Webb jetzt mit all seinen außerordentlichen Fähigkeiten,
wo das irgendwie nicht reicht.
Ist das nur schneller, höher, weiter? Also James Webb zehnmal so groß oder brauchst
du auch noch ganz andere Beobachtungsmethoden?
Ich glaube, momentan am spannendsten finde ich die 21-Zentimeter-Linie.
Und da wäre es natürlich sehr hilfreich, irgendwo hinzugehen,
wo nicht so viele Radiowellen da sind.
Also wenn man sich das vorstellt, selbst in Australien wird man wohl auf irgendwelchen
Radiofrequenzen wird irgendwas gesendet werden.
Die können zum Beispiel dann auch sehen, ob ein Flugzeug oben drüber hinweg fliegt.
Und in der Hinsicht wäre es schon ziemlich cool, wenn wir sozusagen so ein Radiointerferometer
irgendwo außerhalb des Sonnensystems hätten, wenn wir uns jetzt ganz weit greifen.
Also im Prinzip dieses Square-Kilometer-Array im Weltall.
Ja. Dann könnte man es ja auch viel größer machen. Das heißt,
dann hätte man auch eine viel bessere Auflösung.
Also je länger sozusagen denn die verschiedenen, oder je weiter die Stationen
voneinander entfernt sind, desto kleinere Skalen kann man sozusagen messen.
Also quasi so ein Million-Kilometer-Array im Weltall, was dann eben mit dieser,
21-Zentimeter-Linie oder HI-Linie sagt man glaube ich auch oder H1-Linie,
was du so schön bezeichnet hast als so der Tomograf des Universums zu welchem Zeitpunkt nochmal?
Als die Reionisierung angefangen hat sozusagen oder Oder dieser gesamte Bereich,
wo sie stattgefunden hat.
Ja, im Prinzip der ganze Bereich, in dem sie stattgefunden hat und eigentlich
auch davor. Also wir kommen auch in die Dark Ages rein.
Womit man quasi so ein plastisches Bild gewinnen würde des Universums zusätzlich
zu dieser Hintergrundstrahlung, mit der es ja auch zusammenhängt,
um sich ein bisschen fleischiger vorzustellen, wie das alles in seiner Struktur war.
Genau, genau. Man kann sich vorstellen wie so eine 3D-Karte des Universums.
Baut das schon einer?
Bisher gibt es nur Überlegungen, auf den Mond zu gehen.
Da ist natürlich auch immer die Frage, momentan, ich glaube,
der Drang zum Mond ist ziemlich groß.
Und die Frage ist dann, okay, ist es auf dem Mond dann immer noch radio-ruhig?
Also haben wir da nicht viele Radiostörsender?
Ja.
Das ist eben die große Frage.
Das ist überhaupt ein interessantes Problem, dass wir uns ja im Prinzip gerade
die die Weltraumbeobachtung durch unsere eigenen Aktivitäten ganz schön verbauen.
Also man kennt das ja einerseits hier mit den Starlink und vergleichbaren Satellitensystemen,
die also mit diesen vielen Mikrosatelliten sind, die also auch den Blick,
den Lichtblick sozusagen schon einschränken.
Die Gravitationswellen haben schon das Problem, dass Wellen an den Strand schlagen
und im Radiobereich ist es halt einfach die übermäßige Nutzung des Frequenzspektrums
für alle möglichen Anwendungen,
die das sozusagen einschränken.
Aber so krass wird es ja dann glaube ich auf dem Mond erstmal nicht sein, oder? haben.
Ja, definitiv nicht so wie auf der Erde.
Es wird definitiv besser sein. Ich glaube, die Idee ist aber auch,
dass man, wenn man das auf dem Mond baut, im Prinzip in der Sensibilität,
also wie klein das Signal sein könnte, damit man es immer noch detektiert,
wesentlich besser sein würde.
Es würde viel geringer oder Signale geringere Intensität detektieren können.
Und das würde auch dann neue,
Bereiche eröffnen oder Fragen beantworten, die mehr in die Richtung von Materie,
Verteilung oder auch Dark Matter geht.
Ist das nicht so bei der Hintergrundstrahlung, ich meine wir hatten jetzt Planck
sozusagen als bisher die feinste Messung der Hintergrundstrahlung und ich weiß
nicht, ob noch feiner überhaupt was bringen würde.
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal, oder? Also gibt es da nochmal eine Initiative
mit, jetzt brauchen wir das selber, aber nochmal in genauer.
Meine Wahrnehmung war eher so, das passt schon, das haben wir jetzt,
wir könnten eine Auflösung vielleicht noch erhöhen, aber wir würden dabei keine
Informationen gewinnen, die wir nicht im Prinzip schon haben.
Und das war ja eine Mission, die an Lagrange-Punkt L2 weit rausgeflogen,
da hatte man dann irgendwie auch so seine Ruhe, also Ruhe im Sinne von Wärmestrahlung,
Ruhe, also keine warme Sommel in der Nähe und die Erde auch nicht und schön
versteckt im Dunkeln, hat man dann eben sozusagen das Universum abgetastet.
Und dann war das ja nach einer bestimmten Laufzeit dann abgeschlossen.
Wäre das dann mit dieser Messung der H1-Linie, dieser Wasserstofflinie auch so,
dass man das eigentlich nur über einen bestimmten Zeitraum mal messen muss und
dann hat man die Daten und dann kann das Projekt auch beendet sein?
Oder gibt es irgendetwas, wo sinnvoll wäre, das über einen möglichst langen
Zeitraum zu beobachten?
Ja, ich glaube, bei der 21-Zentimeter-Linie macht es schon Sinn,
das über einen längeren Zeitraum zu beobachten, zumal das Signal an sich so klein ist.
Man muss sich das vorstellen, das ist tatsächlich auch wieder ein Hunderttausendstel
von dem eigentlichen Signal.
Also wenn ich 21 Zentimeter das Signal messe, das eigentliche Signal,
an dem ich interessiert bin, ist irgendwie ein Hunderttausendstel davon.
Das heißt, es ist sehr gering.
Und dementsprechend brauchen wir eben relativ viele Daten über einen längeren
Zeitraum, damit wir uns sicher sein können.
Wir kriegen wirklich… Was ist jetzt hier Signal, was ist Rauschen?
Genau, was ist sozusagen der Vordergrund, den wir eigentlich wegsubtrahieren müssen.
Und der kommt hauptsächlich von unserer eigenen Galaxie.
Okay. Und das kann dann, also es könnte sein, dass, was weiß ich,
wenn man das 30 Jahre lang misst, dann hat man immer noch ein besseres Bild,
als wenn man es nur 10 Jahre misst.
Ja, die Statistik wird einfach besser.
Okay.
Wahrscheinlich auch schwer vorher zu sagen, wie lange man jetzt wirklich lauschen muss.
Ist die denn überhaupt schon mal gemessen worden von irgendetwas?
Oder ist das nur so eine theoretische Messung, die man anstrebt?
Naja, also man kann die 21 cm Zentimeterlinie auch von,
Galaxien, die näher an uns dran sind, messen und dann sieht man,
bekommt man sozusagen Karten, wie der neutrale Wasserstoff in den Galaxien verteilt ist. Ähm,
Aber bisher gemessen zur Zeit der ersten Galaxien, der Rionisierung oder dieser
dunklen Zeiten der Dark Ages wurde sie noch nicht.
Es gab eine potenzielle Messung 2018, da gab es eine Publikation,
die gesagt hat, wir haben es detektiert.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile ist der Konsens, da gab es noch Fehler in der Analyse
oder da wurde was nicht genau berücksichtigt. Das ist sehr schwer umstritten.
Und wenn man jetzt sagt, man misst jetzt die Wasserstofflinie von etwas,
was näher dran ist, aber man möchte es lieber von etwas haben,
was weiter weg ist, ist das dann auch wieder so ein Rotverschiebungsaspekt? Perfekt.
Okay, also auch hier muss man sozusagen langwelliger arbeiten,
um tiefer reinzuschauen und dann kann man damit auch im Wesentlichen vorhersagen,
in welche Zeit man schaut.
Genau, genau. Deswegen hat das Square-Kilometer auch zwei Komponenten.
Einen niedrigfrequenten Bereich, der im Megahertz-Bereich ist, der ist in Australien.
Und der andere, der bis in den Gigahertz-Bereich geht, der ist in Südafrika.
Und der in Australien, der fokussiert sich dann auf Rionisierung,
dunkle Zeiten oder Dark Ages.
Und der in Südafrika eher auf die nahegelegenen Galaxien, wie ist der neutrale
Wasserstoff in denen verteilt.
Cool. Bin ich auch mal gespannt, was dabei rauskommt.
Ich auch.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Dann ist hier wieder richtig Alarm.
Ja, Anne, haben wir jetzt eigentlich alles abgeklappert.
Gibt es noch irgendetwas, was du noch gerne hinzufügen möchtest?
Wir haben jetzt, glaube ich, einen recht intensiven Blick auf diese Zeit geworfen.
Ich glaube nicht. Also ich glaube, wir haben einen ganz guten Rundumschlag von
ganz früh bis heute gemacht.
Super, na das freut mich. Dann sage ich vielen Dank für deine Ausführungen.
Danke dir auch.
Ja und damit sage ich auch vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit.
Bald geht es wieder weiter. Ich sage Tschüss und bis bald.